Hier wir gehen, auf der Reise, weißt du nicht, es ist Zeit, uns selbst zu erwerben.
Es ist Freiheit, wie du es nie wusstest.
Du brauchst eine Bade, oder ein Pass.
Sag ein Wort, ich werde dort in einer Flasche sein.
Du kannst sagen, mein Herz steigt auf dich.
Oh, wir können den ganzen Weg zur Mühle von diesem schwarzen, schwarzen Welt.
Komm mit mir, fang mit mir an, oh ja!
Es ist Zeit, in der Luft zu springen, in der Luft zu springen.
Spring, nicht Angst, spring, dann werden deine Kinder weg.
Und wenn die dunklen Flaschen nicht schwimmen,
fühlst du dich nicht als Genitivistin,
dann werde ich deine eine Frau sein.
Also, spring, super heiß, hoch in den Himmel,
in den Himmel, in den Himmel, in den Himmel, in den Himmel.
Du weißt, du bist mein Superstar,
niemand kann mich so weit nehmen.
Ich schiebe den Schlüssel,
get ready for that, so,
jetzt machen wir den Odyssey.
Odyssey, yes, Odyssey, yes,
You know that any captain needs a crew
Take it in stride as you move side to side
They're just different points of view
Jump with me, grab coins with me, oh yeah
Come on and jump up in the air
Jump without a care
Jump up cause you know that I'll be there
And if you find your short on joy
Jump up in the air
Jump up, don't be scared
Jump up and jump up
Jump up cause you know that I'll be there
Jump up, don't be scared
I'll be your one-up girl
Now listen all you boys and girls
All around the world
Warum hab ich den IRL Tag drinne?
Ich hab nen Tag Deutsch, IRL und Creative
Alle drei Tags die ich nicht gesetzt hab und
die ich nicht löschen kann
Ich mein gegen Deutsch, Creative hab ich ja nix
Aber irgendwie ist IRL nicht so ganz passend
Neues Mainboard Gold und geht's mit dem neuen Mainboard?
Ich weiß auch nicht was real life ist
Aber warum mir Twitch unbedingt IRL Tag aufs Auge drücken will, versteh ich auch nicht
Moin, Jakitsu, oh da seh Baros auch da
Keine Quality Options, aber ich hab extra runtergestellt auf 4mbit
Das heißt es sollte eigentlich jeder gucken können
Evoli ist auch am Start, nice
Also, wenn es mit dem neuen Mainboard geht, wäre schon ganz komisch
Oh, ich hab kalte Hände
Wie ein Grill
Echt 1,1 Sekunden Delay?
Ich hab hier extra auch eingestellt Low Latency Streaming
Hab ich eigentlich schon mal erzählt
Wie Twitch Low Latency Streaming überhaupt funktioniert
Ich glaub das hab ich schon mal erzählt
Lass mal kurz gucken ob mein Giftplay überhaupt noch funktioniert
Funktioniert noch
Hier KF
Hallo Janik Official
Okay, aber ich bin ja zumindest vor, dass der Crapbit funktioniert
Meine Programme neigen ja auch irgendwie dazu
Sobald ich sie ein paar Wochen nicht mehr anfasse auf einmal nicht mehr zu gehen
Und dann weiß ich nicht mehr warum
Ich glaub wir müssen den Giftplayer nochmal
Nicht neu machen, aber ich glaub wir müssen den Giftplayer nochmal
Ein bisschen aufräumen, weil ich hab da ein paar grundlegende Fails begangen
Die
Bisschen blöd sind
Zum Beispiel
Hab ich überhaupt nicht eingebaut
Das machen wir mal weg
Fail, das funktioniert nicht
Wobei, wir lassen es mal da
Vielleicht klappt das ja doch
Also erstens hab ich überhaupt nicht bedacht
Dass ich ja
Windows Hotkeys
Vergeben muss, dass ich
Tasten drücken kann zum Bilderchen anzeigen
Das hab ich irgendwie ein bisschen vernachlässigt
Funktioniert jetzt nicht
Und was ich auch vergessen hab ist
Dass wir das Ding zwischendurch anhalten müssen
Evil World Ever
Also bei meinem Tempo wahrscheinlich in drei Jahren oder so
Ich hatte ja heute Morgen kurzzeitig die Idee
Wir schaffen es soweit fertig zu machen, dass wir das irgendwann noch
Vor nächster Woche auf GitHub
Versionen raus machen können, aber
Dann ist mir aufgefallen wie kaputt mein Giftplayer eigentlich ist
Ich mein aktuell das hier
Also sprich die Bilder die sich hier anzeichnet
Und die Gifts played
Das ist ja ein transparentes WPF Fenster
Und ich hab mir also gedacht, ey guck mal
Was die können, das kann ich auch
Und ich wollte den eigenen Giftplayer bauen
Es funktioniert auch und mein Giftplayer ist viel schneller
Viel schneller
Mein Giftplayer ist viel schneller
Und vor allem bei großen Gifts wie dem hier
Auch viel lagfreier oder bei dem Gif hier
Also generell bei größeren Gifts mit viel
Größere Dateikröße haben dann
Da ist er auch viel besser und schneller
Aber ich hab so ein paar Sachen nicht bedacht
Zwischendurch
Und dass die Hotkeys nicht funktionieren und sowas
Das ist fail
Deswegen muss ich jetzt erstmal ausprobieren wie man überhaupt in Windows Hotkeys macht
Also irgendwie so, ich hab hier oben schonmal angefangen hab ich gesehen
Und ich hab aber keine Ahnung was ich da gemacht hab
Ich hab's ja auch absolut nicht null kommentiert
Ich hab irgendwie so eine Windowsdings Funktion überschrieben
Und wenn der Message Code
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen
0.3.1.2 ist, also Hex
Ich weiß es auf Dezimalis
Dann sagt er Keypressed mit diesen Parametern
Ich hab keinen Schimmer, warum?
Ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung was ich da gemacht hab
Best Practice, genau
Massive Best Practice
Musik ist bisschen laut oder?
So ist glaube ich ganz gut
Debaros hast du jetzt im Kopf ausgerechnet oder wie?
Easy
Easy Quick Muffs
Musik
Ja ja doch, der hat ja so ungefähr funktioniert
Das weiß ich, weil
Ich hab hier sowas schon, guck mal
Aber
Ich verwende es nirgendwo
Wir machen jetzt zum Test mal eine simple
Eine simple leere Windows Forms Anwendung
Und machen da mal
Und registrieren da mal ein paar Hotkeys
Und danach müssen wir irgendwie gucken wie wir diesen
Da hab ich aber schon eine Idee
Pausieren können
Weil die Sache ist die
Ich hab
Ich hab mir da am Anfang zu wenig Gedanken drüber gemacht
Und zwar
Mein Problem ist, ich hab jetzt bloß Zeug eingebotzt
Zum starten und stoppen, aber ich brauch was zum pausieren
Und ich will ja nicht jedes Mal wenn ich das Fenster
Ausblende, will ich ja nicht den kompletten Renderkram
Stoppen und dann beim Showen wieder starten
Das dauert ja viel zu lang
Das merkste ja richtig
Auch wenn es bloß irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 150 Millisekunden sind
Aber das merkste halt, wenn du einfach mal Fenster ein- und ausblendest
Und auf einmal lagts
Das ist kacke, deswegen muss ich irgendwie noch so eine
Pausenfunktion einbauen, wo er einfach
Sleep bis das Fenster wieder
Öffnet wird oder so
Aber jetzt probieren wir das erstmal mit Hotkeys aus
So meine besten Projektnamen sind die allerbesten
Windows Forms App 2, Web Application 11, Console App 10
Windows App 10, Windows Forms App 10, Proggers
Console App 9, 7, 11, 8, 6, Meme Board
Es ist der Wahnsinn, Friesi Lul
Das müssen wir auch irgendwann mal fertig machen
Friesi Lul
So, wir machen jetzt was ganz, ganz billiges
Wir nennen es jetzt auch mal ordentlich, Hotkeys
Dass ich wenigstens merken kann, was es ist
So
Hotkeys
Und dann kopieren wir uns mal das, was ich hier schon hab
Weil, das brauchen wir auf jeden Fall
Ich hab das nicht sinnlos damals da rein kopiert, da bin ich mir sicher
Boah, das ist mittlerweile, Visual Studio, echt cool
Dass die, dass die, die haben quasi so das
Das weiste, warum die Leute ReSharper haben wollen
Haben die mittlerweile schon eingebaut, wobei ich mir sicher bin
Dass, ähm, die heißen, äh, JetBrains
Da mittlerweile schon aufgerüstet hatten, das Ding mittlerweile noch mehr kann
Osibaro, wir haben jetzt ein, ein Progas-Projekt
Link
Oh, sehr schön
Staubsaugeroboter, das ist ja auch drin
Sehr schön, das ist cool
Was kannst du nicht, die DLL Imports User32
In den Projekt-Settings machen
Äh, was? Nee
Settings kann ich da nix importieren
Das ist zumal, dass es ja nicht in ein einfacher Import ist
Das ist ja, ist ja quasi managed zu native geschwummelt
Das heißt, ich muss nicht nur sagen, dass
Managed zu native geschwummelt ist
Äh, welche DLL quasi die Funktion enthält
Oder den, den Einstiegspunkt für die Funktion, sondern
Muss den ja auch noch sagen, wie die Signatur aussieht
Weiß er ja nicht
Also, Detlef, ich muss sagen, das ergibt
Das ergibt ja sogar irgendwie dann, was du so schreibst
Ergibt hier irgendwie Sinn, wenn ich mir angucke, was ich hier gemacht hab, ne?
Ich gehe nämlich mal nach dem, was ich hier gemacht habe
Ich gehe nämlich mal davon aus, dass
WMHotkey eben Hex, äh, 312 ist
Ah, tatsächlich
Da hab ich mir sogar was bei gedacht, das ist schon mal nicht schlecht
Also, probieren wir das mal aus
Also, probieren wir das mal aus, also
Wie das mit Hotkeys funktioniert
WNdingsproc muss man überschreiben
So, und was hab ich dann hier gemacht?
Ok, das wäre eigentlich super simple, ne?
Kommen wir mal weg
Und, und dann machen wir uns hier in, in die net
Das war mal irgendwie noch so ein
Äh, was war das hier, Dings?
Static, Const, wie auch immer
Kann man Static, oder kann man das? Das geht nicht, oder?
Ähm
War mal irgendwie sowas
Kind, ne
Gut, jetzt haben wir den Krempel hier
Und jetzt testen wir das mal
Gucken wir mal, ob das jetzt echt funktioniert
So, und jetzt müssen wir erst ein paar Hotkeys
Registern, dass das klappt
Also, Loaded
Loaded, gibt's nicht sowas wie Loaded?
Äh, Shown, Shown
Shown heißt es in Windows Formtile
So, und da jetzt
Register Hotkey
Hab ich Hotkey eigentlich so hässlich da geschrieben?
Was meint ihr, ihr schöner Hotkey?
Hot und Key, oder Hotkey in einem Wort?
Ich tendiere, nachdem ich mir jetzt so angucke, eigentlich eher zu Hotkey ein Wort
Ah, das ist Shown
Die Probleme, ja, das sind First Program Problems
Ja, das mach ich dann, ich muss erstmal
Äh, ausprobieren, so
Ja, dieser Hotkey, sondern ist das, äh, mein Window Handle, weil es ist ja Windows, ID
Das hab ich natürlich ganz besonders clever benannt
Das heißt wirklich ID
Ach so, das ist einfach nur irgendwie so ein
Einfach irgendwas, was ich mir aussuchen kann
ID, deswegen ein Beispiel für ID 1
Wenn sonst nichts geht
Äh, Modifier, ja, da müssen wir jetzt mal gucken
Modifier, Modifier Alt, Control, wir machen nochmal einen Test mit Control
Control
Und dann VK, was ist das?
Was, was sind, Virtual Key Codes, aha
So, und da machen wir jetzt L, suchen wir jetzt da
Weil L quasi wie LUL
Null CH, Hauptsache Hex, mehr Hex, please
So, jetzt hab ich den Kram registert
Das heißt jetzt ja
Hotkey, das heißt, wenn ich jetzt, also von der Idee her
Wenn ich jetzt, Steuerung L drück, dann checkt er das und sagt Hotkey
So
Was?
Ah, das muss so heißen, oder?
Moment, das Ding heißt ja so
Das kann ich mir gar nicht aussuchen, das Ding heißt ja so
Ja, okay, dann war die Frage eigentlich komplett überflüssig
Das Ding heißt irgendwie noch so, ich kann es ja nicht logischerweise nicht einfach umbenennen, wie ich will
Ja, das ist schon klar
Aber ich will ja mal gucken, ob es überhaupt funktioniert
Quatsch, wir müssen doch Konsole einplanen
So, Punkt
Das Fenster move sich schon mal
Ah, Moment
Control L ist schon belegt
Ich brauche mal irgendwas, was nicht belegt ist
Hier, hier ist bestimmt nicht belegt
Ah, Hotkey, es funktioniert
Nice, das ist schön
Das ist gut zu sehen
Vollgas, Alter
Okay, jetzt mal Musik anmachen
Epic
Oh, nee, das ist ja, das ist schon so abgenutzt, ey
Das, kennt ihr, das ist die Dinge, was das Heart of Courage oder sowas
Also das, ja genau
Das hatte man eine Zeit lang, jede Montage, jeder Trailer als Intro drinnen
Ist on Show in einer Art Weilschleife
Was? Nö, wie kommst du da drauf?
Ich habe mir einen neuen Rechner für 1300 Euro gekauft, der schafft es aber noch nicht mal World of Warships
Auf Mittel mit 60 FPS laufen zu lassen
Das ist bitter
World of Warships ist ja noch nicht dafür bekannt, dass der geile Huddlefresser ist
Was ist denn da drinnen?
Wobei, für 1300 Euro kann da eigentlich nichts so schlechtes drin sein, als World of Warships nicht läuft
Was, TS? Ich komme jetzt nicht ins TS
Ich bin gerade am Streamsort
So, also das mit dem Hotkey funktioniert
So, und wie habe ich das jetzt hier gemacht?
Das ist typisch Windows-Krempel, ey
Das ist wieder so, was soll das, so Magic-Parameter oder was ist das da?
Okay, und ich vermute mal, dass da dann drinnen steht meine ID, ne?
Da steht dann wahrscheinlich hier eins drin, denke ich mal
Ja, okay, nice, das funktioniert
Also du kannst gerne im Chat schreiben, was du für einen Rechner gekauft hast
Dann können wir da mal unseren Senf zugeben
Das ist aber echt so wieder typisch Windows-Kram
Eine Sache habe ich gemerkt, Samstagabends ist immer schlechte Zeit zum Streben, aber wenn das die Leute zugucken
Also da guckt irgendwie keiner Twitch, was ich auch verstehen kann, damit die Leute besseres zu tun
Kann nicht jeder so no-live machen wie ich
Wie schreibst du eigentlich mehr Zeit in den Kommentaren?
Also, ich mache immer so, blablabla
Ich mache nie, ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Sündtags geht ehrlich gesagt
Sternchen, Sternchen, Slash oder irgendwie so
Guck mal, sogar Visual Studio macht es für einen so
Was ist Sternchen, Slash, Slash, Sternchen
Ne, warte mal, blablabla
Und dann, ich kann auch nicht mal die Sündtags dafür, okay so
Ne, mache ich nicht, sieht auch kacke aus finde ich
Ich mache immer so, ich mache immer so
Wenn ich, wenn ich einen Kommentar mehr zeige, ich habe immer
Das mit Sternchen geht mir auf den Keks
Das einzige, wo ich es noch irgendwie verstehen kann, ist wenn die Leute irgendwie sowas machen
Aber das ist, das ist eh dieses komische Microsoft XML, wenn die irgendwie so längere Dinge so haben
Oder vielleicht, vielleicht wenn man irgendwie so, also okay, vielleicht wenn man den Lizenzgedöns irgendwie 80 Zeilen am Start immer hat
Oder so, okay, aber ansonsten
Ich habe zu wenig gestrebt in Dezember, ich darf mich nicht mehr werben
Als Partner
Muss jetzt erst noch ein paar Tage streben, dann darf ich wieder
Was ich, was ich als Comments immer ganz gerne habe ist so
So was hier
Achtung, und dann irgendwie eine ordentliche Schrift
Also ich mache das normalerweise nicht im Web, ich mache das
So was hier, das, das mache ich, das mag ich irgendwie
Wenn ich auf dreimal die Woche komme, mal muss ich nachgucken
Ne, ne, du musst nicht auf dreimal die Woche, du musst auf
Für Partner musst du was, 12 mal im Monat oder so
Wie macht man das, der Hotkey auch funktioniert, wenn andere Tasten gedrückt werden, also ich meine Schrift, alt
Was meinste, genau
Ich muss jetzt wahrscheinlich, ich denke mal, ich muss heute und morgen noch streben, dann müsste ich eigentlich genug Strebs haben
Ach so, du meinst, dass das
Du meinst, dass du mehr als eine, ich vermute mal, die wird man odern oder so, denke ich mal
Probieren wir mal aus, weiß es ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
Probieren wir mal aus, sollen wir mal alt noch dabei
So, jetzt müsste ich Steuerung alt 4 und nicht Steuerung alt f4 drücken
Ja, genau, jetzt muss Steuerung alt 4 drücken, also bei der Gelegenheit können wir das übrigens gerade mal ein bisschen schöner machen
Ne, wir machen dann
Wie nennen wir das schön, wie nennen wir das hier, Mod, Mod, Mod alt
Was ist natürlich alles Mod alt, WTF, Mod control
Nee, Schiff brauchen wir nicht, Windows Taste, Windows Taste, das ist 128
Das ist so, das haben sie bei dieser ganzen Epic Trailer Music, haben sie immer so, dass die haben immer so Chor drin, ohne dass der was sagt, der macht immer nur so
Die sagen ja nichts, die haben ja kein Text.
Nein, wir riften hier keine Websites.
So, das heißt...
Lautstärke, okay, mir kommt so laut vor, aber
wenn ich mir das angucke, ist das eigentlich gar nicht zu laut.
Ja, genau, Sebaro, bam.
Bin irgendwie müde, ich kann mich immer weiter konzentrieren.
So, ähm, genau, wir wollen...
Vielleicht soll ich...
Mal jetzt mal mal links hier, Mod.
Mod Control.
Geht's wahrscheinlich besser, ne?
Mach doch einen 24-Stunden-Streben.
Nee, das halt ich nicht aus.
Bin ich zu alt für mittlerweile?
Wahrscheinlich kriege ich ja den
24-Stunden-Streamer.
Nee.
Was kann...
Rodern beim Übergeben...
Moment, was kann...
Rodern beim Übergeben von Parametern...
in eine Funktion.
Achtung, meint es das hier?
Nee, nee, nee, das ist, das ist
bevor es die Funktion kriegt.
Also wenn ich sowas hier mache,
dann ist das im Endeffekt, was ist?
01 und...
Also 01 oder 02
und der neue Wert, der da rauskommt,
der wird dann an die Funktion übergeben.
Echt, es gibt Leute mit 76, die
24-Streams machen das.
Nicht schlecht.
Ja.
Deswegen sind es ja auch immer
Power of Two quasi so,
dass du es als Flex verwenden kannst.
1, 2, 4, 8 und 4000.
Weil Microsoft...
Das ist auch geil.
Die Microsoft-Logik.
1, 2, 4, 8, 4000.
Vielleicht wollten sie sich einfach
ein bisschen was frei halten oder so.
Ich weiß es nicht.
So, und jetzt...
So, jetzt haben wir das,
die Registrat.
Und jetzt steht aus irgendwelchen
Magic-Funden
steht die ID, die wir oben
vergeben haben.
In...
M...
Also in...
Warum nennen wir das eigentlich M?
Warum nennen wir das nicht Message?
Wie besser.
Na, wobei.
Message ist bescheuert.
Warum gibt es denn überhaupt
M-Punkt-Message?
Das ist voll doppelt.
Egal.
Das Ding, wenn Microsoft meint,
das soll scheinbar M heißen,
okay, dann lassen wir es halt so.
So, und jetzt
ist auf Magic-Art und Weise
in MW-Param unsere
ALDI von da oben drin.
Aha.
Intuitiver könnte es ja quasi
gar nicht sein.
So, und jetzt kann ich quasi gucken,
ob meine ALDI...
Jetzt müsste ich mir natürlich
meine Hotkeys irgendwie merken.
Brauche ich irgendwie so eine Hotkey-Class?
Probieren wir das doch mal aus.
Probieren wir das doch mal.
Na ja.
Hotkey-Class. Probieren wir mal, ob ich...
Ich habe mir da keine Gedanken
zugemacht bisher, aber...
Das wird nicht so schwierig sein.
Wir haben irgendwie eine Hotkey-Class, aber irgendwie sowas wie
ID.
So, und dann brauchen wir
die Funktion, die
aufgerufen werden soll.
Wenn...
Wenn da
Hotkey gedrückt wird,
das könnte man doch so machen
in der Richtung.
Irgendwie so in der Richtung.
Ich bin mir da noch nicht so ganz sicher, wie wir das machen.
Hotkey-Mapper-Factory-Manager.
Genau.
Service muss da noch rein.
Das ist der Hotkey...
Das ist der Hotkey-Service.
Also, das ist...
Man darf den Hotkey... Also Java-Style.
Man darf den Hotkey schon mal nicht selbst erstellen.
Es gibt ein Hotkey...
Hotkey-Service, und dann gibt es
ein Hotkey-Service-Manager
und eine Hotkey-Service-Manager-Factory,
die auch wiederum gemanagt
werden muss. Also ein Hotkey-
Service-Manager-Factory-Manager.
Dann... Da können wir uns...
Dann können wir uns bei irgendeiner Konferenz bewerben
und halten einen Vortrag über geile Design-Pattern,
nachdem wir das gemacht haben.
Ihr müsst euch mal...
Ihr müsst euch mal manche Vorträge angucken.
Hab ich den Eindruck, die werden echt nur gehalten,
um sie zu halten.
Da hast du dann irgendeinen...
Das hab ich euch ja schon mal erzählen, ne?
Da hab ich... Ist schon ein paar Jahre her,
hab ich mal so einen Ruby... So einen Vortrag von irgendeiner
Ruby-Konferenz geguckt und...
Ich glaub, so wie Ruby-Leute sind
sehr pingelig, was...
Die... Die Optik
von ihrem Source-Code angeht.
Und...
Und da war so ein Oberruby-
Pattern-Guru auf der Konferenz
und hat einen Vortrag gehalten. Und...
Der hat natürlich auch Ruby-
Style-Wim verwendet und hat sich permanent
während der Konferenz verzettelt mit irgendwelchen
Key-Bindings.
Und...
Und dann hat er irgendwann in seinem Vortrag
erzählt, er ist der Meinung,
quasi jede... Jede...
Methode, die mehr
als eine Zeile enthält, ist schlecht.
So sinngemäß, hat er das gesagt.
Und da hab ich mir auch gedacht, soll ich jetzt
einfach instant ausmachen, durfte es
Kommentar drunter schreiben oder mir einfach denken,
er schwätzt nur.
Das kenn ich, Tomica,
das kenn ich. Oder gibt's da
Neues mittlerweile?
Macht doch eine Class mit einer Map,
bei der ein Hotkey auf eine Lambda-
Funktion gemapped wird, die dann entsprechend fun-
das ist doch hier.
So was in der Richtung soll das doch
werden.
Ich bin übelst müde, ich weiß auch nicht warum.
Nur seit ich Urlaub hab, kann ich gefühlt
pennen bis...
so lange ich will.
Ich bin quasi keinen Tag jetzt vor 9 Uhr
aufgestanden. Aber ich bin trotzdem müde.
Das ist doch eigentlich eine Kombination, das geht doch
eigentlich gar nicht.
Ich hab wieder zu viel gepennt.
Aber wir machen mal das andere zu,
sonst verwirrt es mich.
Drei Sachen auch.
Ah, Sepharo.
Ich bin voll brain-lack gerade.
Okay.
Ähm.
Vollwerkblatt, ja?
Also, das heißt wir...
Brain-I-O, oder was?
Ich würde eher sagen
Lack. Versuche ich so
Try-Take.
Und da kommt immer False zurück.
Try-Take, was
machen wir jetzt? False. Ne, ne.
Try-Take, was machen wir jetzt? False.
So ungefähr fühlt sich das im Kopf
gerade an.
Ist die Musik auf einmal wieder
übelst leise? Können die sich das mal überlegen?
Dass es immer irgendwie gleich laut
bleibt.
So, jetzt haben wir unseren Hotkey
Registered.
So, New Hotkey.
So.
Irgendwie, wie man das...
Ne, das ist hässlich. Das machen wir nicht so.
Nein.
Shit, kommt wieder weg.
Konstruktor machen wir.
Mit
ID und Action
Callback. So ist das doch viel besser.
Zack.
Zack. Da wissen wir nämlich auch, dass da was drin ist.
Jetzt wissen wir, dass da was drin ist. Viel besser.
Ob das jetzt von der Idee her funktioniert, was ich da vorhab.
Also, Hotkey 1.
Callback.
Ähm.
Sowas da.
Oh, was weiß ich noch mal. Callback.
Ähm.
Callback.
O-M-E-G-A-L.
Lul.
Bester Callback.
So, dann machen wir uns noch irgendwie eine Liste
mit Hotkeys drin.
Hotkey.
Ähm.
Keys.
So.
Packen wir das da irgendwie
rein.
Jetzt auch mal für uns formatieren können, oder?
Bildlich.
Formatiert es das jetzt für uns?
So.
Ähm.
Eigentlich wäre vielleicht besser,
wenn wir ein Dictionary machen mit
ID.
Dann ist der Zugriff schneller.
Nicht, dass es überhaupt
irgendwie was ausmachen würde bei der Liste
mit einem Element oder so. Oder bei der Liste
unter ein paar Millionen Elementen.
Ähm. So.
So, das heißt, da können wir jetzt gucken.
Ob wir in unserer
Hotkey-List...
Ja, das macht auch was aus.
Das macht verdammt viel aus.
Das macht direkt Zugriff oder linear
suchen aus.
Also quasi instant und...
Also quasi von instant
klar macht es das aus.
Praktisch gesehen macht das
halt überhaupt nichts aus.
Und, was auch witzig ist in der heutigen
Zeit...
Was geht jetzt mit der Musik ab?
Moin, Matt Key.
Was auch witzig ist,
früher
waren wir ja ganz scharf auf
Binary Search.
Also sprich, zur Mitte gesucht,
kleiner, größer.
Und, ähm...
Mittlerweile muss man sich das echt
überlegen, ob man Binary Searched.
Oftmals bist du einfach mit purer
Prozessor-Power linear
geradeaus in your face suchen.
Schneller als mit wildem
Binary Search rumgejumpe.
Übrigens ist Binary Search
auch... Habt ihr euch schon mal gefragt,
warum die meisten
Suchtools
beziehungsweise die
meisten Suchprogramme,
Suchmaschinen, was auch immer,
den Index verwenden?
Warum die, äh...
Warum die keinen Wildcards
als erstes Zeichen erlauben?
Das liegt genau daran,
weil der Index
quasi sortiert ist, von A bis Z
und...
weil die Binary Search
im Index machen.
Und wenn du als Wildcard
das erste Zeichen nimmst, kannst du kein
Binary Search beim Index machen, weil wie willst du das machen?
Du hast ja keinen Anfang...
Du hast ja keinen Anfang mehr.
Falls mir jetzt überhaupt
geistig jemand folgen konnte, was ich vorhin gegeben hab.
Deswegen kannst du
bei den meisten Suchtools
nicht beim ersten Zeichen
ne Wildcard machen.
Manchmal so Sachen wie
Gap und so ist das kein Problem.
Die haben ja keinen Index.
Ich penn echt gleich eins, das ist der Wahnsinn heute.
Ich glaub ich hätte den Stream auslassen sollen.
Ich bin Übelsmüll.
Und ich weiß nicht warum.
Gap.
Äh.
Moment, das kann nicht funktionieren, was ich da mach.
Und es ergibt
eigentlich auch nicht wirklich Sinn.
Ich brauch das kann ich, ich brauch so was hier.
I.D.
Set private.
So was brauch ich.
Viel besser.
I.D.
Ja, so funktioniert das.
So, jetzt hab ich den Hotkey.
Äh.
Jetzt hab ich den Hotkey.
Ich probier das gleich mal aus.
Da ist aber hier if.
Gucken wir mal ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Hab ich gemapped.
Immer noch vier.
Control vier.
Nee, funktioniert nicht.
Nee, was hab ich?
Control.
Äh, äh, äh, alt, alt,
Control vier.
Okay, das funktioniert.
Ich mach jetzt mal da wieder
einfach nur Control draus.
Vielleicht zu wenig genug, kann sein.
Eigentlich nicht.
Aber könnte, könnte sein.
Jetzt hab ich jetzt nicht mehr was zu trinken.
Hier muss ich dann, muss ich gleich mal was holen.
So.
Gucken ob da Frasier was geschrieben hat.
Ich bin echt froh, dass Discord, ähm,
überall läuft.
Als desktop App.
Auf Linux, im Browser,
überall.
Brogaustira Fox, ja.
Aber ich bin übelst müde.
Es kann, es kann sein, dass ich nicht lange
Broga, Broger ran.
Auch unter Symbian. Wenn das einen ordentlichen
Browser hat mit JavaScript Support, dann schon.
Aber das bezweifelt.
Ich bezweifle es, dass es irgendwie
einen halbwegs aktuellen Browser hat.
Oh.
Wir können, wir können einfach sagen,
if first or default
und wenn Hotkey nicht null ist,
dann gibt es den nämlich.
Das kann man wahrscheinlich auch viel schöner machen.
Mit neuem C-Sharp.
Neuer C-Sharp 7.
Sündags.
Aber ich kann gerade nicht
richtig denken.
So.
Und.
Das müssen wir übrigens
auch so machen.
Ich glaube,
das funktioniert an der Stelle nicht,
weil das kannst du nicht auf Properties anmelden,
sondern nur auf Methoden.
Also du meinst hier den da, ne?
Ähm.
Ja.
Die Musik, die geht ab.
So als passiert jetzt hier irgendwas Tolles.
Ups.
Ähm.
Voll weg.
So.
Und nun, jetzt haben wir den Hotkey gefunden.
Und dann können wir
das auslösen.
Callback.
Da könnte man jetzt sowas machen hier.
Sowas könnte man an der Stelle machen.
Invoke.
So und von der Idee her, wenn ich jetzt, äh,
Ctrl 4 drücke,
sollte dann da stehen
Omega null.
So.
So weit
von der Idee her.
Probier mal aus.
Bam.
Guck mal, es funktioniert auch,
wenn ich in anderen Anwendungen drinne bin.
Sieht man jetzt nicht richtig.
Weil, ich mein,
so, also.
Guck mal, wir gehen jetzt aber ein bisschen
ins Windows Explorer, sonst wie.
Also das ist globaler
Hotkey.
Das ist doch schön.
Wo hab ich eigentlich kein
Omega null
Audio mehr in meinem Neamtool.
Das muss ich gerade mal, gerade mal
hinzufügen.
Omega null.
Description Text, Omega null.
Oh.
Weiß gar nicht, ob ihr das gehört habt, aber das sollte eigentlich auch.
Ah.
Alternativ geht das Ganze
auch auf Koreanisch.
Oder auch nicht.
Der Weebservice ist kaputt.
Ich glaub,
die haben ihre API geändert.
Der Weebservice hat ihre
API geändert.
Funktioniert nicht mehr.
Nur noch die Sachen, die ich schon runter
geladen hab.
Oh nee.
Ah.
Oh.
Es ist abgekackt. Habt ihr das gesehen?
Es ist abgekackt.
Es hat irgendeine Exception exceptioned.
Ich hab natürlich nicht
damit gerechnet, dass das
die koreanische Web
API jemals nen Fehler wirft.
Deswegen hab ich da auch keinerlei
Exception handling eingebaut, weil wer
könnte denn damit rechnen, dass
die koreanische Web API jemals nen Fehler wirft?
Denn das ist vollkommen abwegig.
Ach stimmt.
Japanisch. Die japanische API
war das. Richtig.
Aber wenigstens
haben wir wieder.
Wir können mal gucken, was passiert,
wenn er abkackt hier.
Da muss ich aber glaube ich mal den
Debugger anmachen. Mal gucken, was er mit
Wasser abscheißt.
Mal gucken, mit was er abscheißt.
Ich weiß mittlerweile schon,
dass ich Web Application
11 haben will.
Ich guck mal,
was er abkackt.
Auf Start Hots.
So.
Ok.
Mal gucken. Also.
Ich machs mal hier auf, dass ihr seht,
was ich mache.
So. Das ist
das Web Interface, was ich auf dem zweiten Rechner habe.
Für Bilder anzeigen.
Und Zeug.
So. Und jetzt
rollte ich
die Weeb Variante
von Omega Lul.
N.
Normal
funktioniert.
Wenn ich auf
Weeb umschalte.
Oh. Geht doch.
Ok. Funktioniert.
Ich weiß nicht was.
Wahrscheinlich hat es nur kurzzeitig
gespackt.
Das ist ja
komplett verarscht.
Omega Lul.
Ich glaube,
damit kommt die japanische
Text-to-Speech-Ending
nicht so ganz klar.
Omega Lul.
Das ist so, das ist so dumm.
Das ist richtig dumm.
Omega Lul kann sie ja nicht.
Das haben wir ja schon mal ausprobiert.
Jetzt wird er...
Ah doch.
Das kann sie ja nicht.
Das haben wir ja schon mal ausprobiert.
Das klappt nicht.
Ich stelle gerade fest,
dass ich das viel besser gebaut
habe, als ich
in Erinnerung habe. Ich cache das hier zwischendurch.
Wenn ich jetzt nämlich klicke,
ist das instant da.
Was
können wir noch mal
ausprobieren?
In der japanischen
Text-to-Speech-Engine.
Was
können wir noch mal ausprobieren?
Brokers.
Okay, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Das kann es bestimmt.
Oh!
Brokase.
Besser als
ich gedacht hätte.
Das ist sogar noch besser.
Die
Dinger
reagieren auch auf
Ausrufezeichen und
Leerzeichen und so. Da muss man
noch ein bisschen ausprobieren.
Was wupplo hast?
Okay.
Was?
Moment.
Das hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Was?
Okay.
Oh!
Wirklich besser ist es jetzt auch
nicht.
Wirklich besser ist es auch nicht.
Man erkennt jetzt zumindest
ungefähr, was er sagt.
Was?
Wampurose.
Der Direktor.
Eigentlich
mir fällt gerade, ich muss eigentlich nur den Text ändern.
Ich muss es hier oben überhaupt nicht ändern.
Oh, das ist gut.
Das ist gut.
Das ist nice. Das gefällt mir.
Das finde ich gut.
Das kann ich mal ändern.
Okay.
Moment.
Oh, nein.
Das kann sie nicht.
Warte mal. Die Musik.
ist gut ist gut genug epische musik
it's s. das ist auch gut, das ist auch nice. das ist auch gut. das muss ich mir auch speichern
die kombination finde ich gut
das geht natürlich umgedreht. so hat noch einer glorreiche ideen oder können wir weiter machen
ach seffi das kann das glaube ich nicht ich glaube das kann sie nicht
gar nicht mal so schlecht gar nicht mal so schlecht gar nicht mal so schlecht
das ist auch geil
das ist doch das finde ich auch das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht
gut wie dem auch sei ich würde sagen wir machen mal weiter
das finde ich das finde ich nice hier
okay weiter weiter im text
also man wurde immer stehen geblieben control 4 löst das aus okay nice
im kern ist das ja eigentlich schon das was wir brauchen hotkey stels hotkey
registern wir könnten jetzt um den jawa leuten eine freude zu machen einen hotkey manager einführen
der für uns hotkeys registert
weil ich neige ich neige ja gerade dazu weil mir weil mir nichts kürzeres knackigeres
einfällt könnte man ein könnte man ein statisches int irgendwie in die hotkey klasse machen
was einfach aufgezählt wird es müsste einfach die einfachste variante sein oder
also von der idee her ich weiß ich würde ja auch gerne den java style hotkey manager
factory service erstellen aber könnten wir nicht einfach so was hier machen
und dann dass man dass man das da quasi dann machen wir nämlich das da privat
so kurz lieber komplizierte klasse genau und dann müssten dann müssten wir jetzt eigentlich
schon im privat ich weiß also ich in der regel sagt man ja irgendwie so statisches zeug ist
an sich immer nicht nicht nicht nicht so schön und nicht so nicht so best practice genau in
dem fall fällt mir eigentlich jetzt nichts kürzer knackigeres ein dass wir jetzt irgendwie
was sagen irgendwie private static ins und dann machen wir einfach und was weiß ich counter
da machen wir einfach hier quasi jedes mal den counter eins hoch und machen einen neuen
hotkey damit das heißt hier müssen wir jetzt im prinzip nur die action übergeben voll
weg und wenn wir sogar in line machen und dann sagen wir einfach nur und das geben wir dann
zurück als hotkey das müsste doch eigentlich ganz gut funktionieren wie wäre es mit dem
in 64 du meinst zur sicherheit falls einer paar milliarden hotkeys anlegt mehr als es
tasten kombinationen gibt wobei das ist das ist eine interessante frage könnten uns theoretisch
das könnte uns das ausgehen weil ich mein man kann jede tast mit jedem mit jedem modifier
machen und die modifier in kombination das glaube ich gar nicht so einfach auszurechnen
wie viel man kriegt aber ich vermute mal dass es eine saumäßig große zahl ist ich glaube
das ist eine unglaublich große zahl was du für maximale tasten kombis machen kannst
mit shortcuts und shortcuts mit shortcuts mit modifier und modifier kombiniert da könnte
uns tatsächlich in 32 nicht ausreißen
der raven ist auch am start jetzt müssen wir das hier austauschen und zwar moment den
jetzt können wir jetzt können wir den den den hotkey das hotkey registrieren könnten
wir hier noch rein machen oder dass das wir ah nee nee das ist doof weil wir das window
nicht haben das ist das ist das ist nicht so schön das
gefällt mir nicht aber machen wir erst mal hotkey
das finde ich nicht so schön da müssen wir uns noch was anderes über
weil uns bringt das jetzt so gar nicht wirklich was weil wir können jetzt wir können jetzt
zwar sagen hotkey id das funktioniert zwar aber viel schöner wäre es wenn der hotkey
das macht doch nix ich versuche meinen gift player den hier nee moment ich habe den gift
player zugemacht ich versuche meinen gift player zu verbessern der also der gift player
der mal das gift plane hier ablösen soll weil er weniger ram braucht und schneller
ist plus ich war so clever und hab nicht dran gedacht dass das ding auch hotkeys können
muss das ist so ein tick von mir ich finde es geil dass die leute schon wissen den gift
player meine ich der direkt x high speed gift player mit 4000 fps das ist der schnellste
gift player der welt dann gleich gleich guinness buch anrufen weltrekord ja und nicht nur fps
sondern fps die sekunde 8000 kriegst du mit dem statischen bild locker hin
fps die sekunde na klar so und mir ist aufgefallen dass ich da ein paar sachen nicht so clever
gelöst hab drinnen und zwar einmal das hotkeys nicht ordentlich durchdacht sind und vor allem
dass ich noch nichts eingebaut haben eingebaut habe dass man das ding pausieren kann ich
hab bloß eingebaut dass man das komplette rendern stoppen und starten kann und aktuell
muss ich um pause zu machen quasi komplett stoppen und dann beim fenster anzeigen wieder
starten das ist ziemlich blöd doch und jetzt bin ich grad dabei zu lernen wie man winnars
hotkeys macht also sprich wie man wie man in winnars globale hotkeys macht das probiere
ich gerade aus was funktioniert auch guck hier also wenn ich steuerung f4 drücke und
auch wenn ich in dem wenn ich jetzt hier in chrome oder so bin drück steuerung 4 und registriert
den hotkey also sprich da ist global das ist schon mal nice ja sebaro man kann man kann
es relativ einfach also jetzt aktuell renner das gibt ja mit also es gibt eine ganz einfache
variante um es auf auf 144 herz zu beschränken das ist weil man einfach wie sync anwacht
das ist simpel da muss man nämlich einfach eine eins reinschreiben und dann ist wie sync
an wie man sieht mit wie sync braucht das ding auch wie man hier sieht eine ganze ecke
weniger cpu und ohne jetzt mal zum vergleich ohne wie sync ist schon ein bisschen mehr
und es sind ja acht ne sechs kerne also das dürften irgendwie dann das ist halt der core
ist halt voll und es sind sogar noch ein bisschen mehr als ein core weil der der render
dings der das gif also das ffm pack im hintergrund wer das gif macht das ist ja in dem eichstra
thread läuft er läuft er parallel allerdings bloß für 100 bilder im voraus also der wartet
zum größten teil aber wie fp ist ja richtig
da mal die hotkey geschichten so wird man wieder aber nachdem das jetzt funktioniert
weil ich konnte wie könnte man da was schönes draus machen mit den hotkeys also ich hätte
ja gerne hätte ja irgendwie gerne dass der dass der super krasse hotkey die hotkey manager
service factory singleton manager der factory das ganze macht kannst du nicht einfach nichts
rendern näher nichts rendern würde auch cpu last verursachen dann läuft die schleife
halt schneller dann habe dann habe ich halt 50.000 fps nichts gerendert was auch dazu
führt dass ich massig viel cpu verprate also was ich eigentlich machen muss zum können
jetzt mal kurz dazwischen schieben weil die pause rendern ist relativ einfach wenn ich
pause rennen rennen pausieren ist relativ einfach also aktuell ist ja so ich muss erst
einmal ich kann das jetzt nicht auch ein und ausblenden gescheit weil ich halt keine hotkeys
drin haben aber nur nur von der idee her das das machen wir dann richtig wenn ich dort
habe von der idee ist das relativ einfach mit mit dem warten zum rennen wir brauchen
in den weight handle also in den also nur mal exemplarisch wir würden da irgendwie
sowas machen sowas so irgendwie keine blocker der ist standardmäßig standardmäßig gesetzt
also sprich standardmäßig blocker nix und dann würde ich den würde ich irgendwo reinsetzen
in die schleife sagen wir mal so hier ok und dann sage ich wait das geht jetzt nicht weil
ich nichts habe um das auszulösen aber von der idee her so und das wäre es im endeffekt
schon mehr müsste ich zum rennen pausieren eigentlich gar nicht machen und jetzt müsste
ich irgendwie einfach sagen reset und dann wirds blocken es wird so lange blocken bis
ich sage wieder set aus dem anderen thread raus das ist das ist eigentlich alles was
ich zum zum render pausieren machen müsste so weit in der theorie
problem ist dass ich halt dadurch dass ich keine hotkeys hab jetzt ein transparentes
fenster halt nicht also ein transparentes fenster das keine mausklicks und tastatureingaben
annimmt richtig halt nicht minimieren und maximieren kann weil wie ich hab sie extra
so eingestellt dass es nicht interagiert irgendwie deswegen basteln wir jetzt erstmal ein bisschen
hotkey und dann bauen wir die hotkey geschichte da ein wobei guck mal ich hab doch hier oben
schon sowas in der richtung eingebaut hier wir probieren das jetzt einfach mal aus mit
render pausieren das kann also schwierig sein hotkey breast bla bla bla im endeffekt schon
genau wobei da ein bisschen mehr ein bisschen mehr magic noch drunter ist weil das nicht
idle weighted also das das schwachsinn das nicht spinn wie nennt man das spinn weighted
wie heißt das odd weighted wie nennt man das richtig also du kannst ja auf verschiedene
arten spinn lock genau du kannst ja auf verschiedene arten kannst ja warten du kannst ja entweder
kannst du sleepen das heißt im endeffekt dass du deinem betriebssystem thread task
sonst was scheduler scheduler sagst ich brauch deine zeit nicht ich geb meinen zeit slot
gebe ich ab alles gut dann kannst du sleepen was dazu führt dass bei nem sleep die sache
halt nicht genau getimt werden kann also sprich wenn du sagst sleep 10 millisekunden da können
das auch 13 millisekunden sein das weiß man nicht genau so und die andere variante ist
dass man eben quasi so so busy weighted so dass man dass man quasi eine endlosschleife
laufen lässt mit einem timer und bald der timer halt soweit ist geht man aus der endlosschleife
raus kannst du mir das erklären ja kann ich dann nehmen wir nehmen wir am besten dann
nehmen wir mal die neue anwendung die wir gerade aufgemacht haben da ist da ist nicht
wirklich viel drin unser hotkey testing das ist immer ein machen was war in der c++ sprache
immer ein zeiger auf die aktuelle instanz von deiner klasse also zum beispiel habe ich
ja hier meine meine form die im endeffekt leer ist also die hier die und noch nichts
drin ist und wenn ich da drin in this verwende dann bezieht sich das immer auf das was gerade
also in dem code wo ich gerade drin bin auf die instanz die das die instanz die gerade
läuft oder die gerade ausgeführt wird in der quasi mein code gerade läuft auf die bezieh
ich mich mit das glaube das war eine übelst beschissene erklärung aber ich meine man
versteht glaube ich ganz gut ja und was auch noch was auch noch ganz ganz interessant ist
es gibt noch eine zweite sache genau kiste hd dann gibt es eine zweite sache die ist
auch ganz interessant in c sharp dann ist das wobei das ist nicht unbedingt explosiv das
ist base und base bezieht sich eigentlich auf falls du irgendwie eine klasse hast die
von einer anderen klasse was geerbt hat und du möchtest und du hast das überschrieben
nur möchtest allerdings jetzt unbedingt das aus der base klasse aufrufen und nicht deins
dann kannst du sagen base und das war eigentlich so die zwei dinger die skippt ich bin so müde
heute ist der wahnsinn reinauer resident sleeper wo habe ich denn denn ok wie könnte man das
jetzt hier schön machen mit den hotkeys also eigentlich ich meine die die billigste variante
ist dem create hotkey noch das händel mit zu übergeben aber das ist nicht schön oder
wenn ich dem das händel übergebe wenn ich dem das händel übergebe dann kann ich sowas
hier machen da kann ich nämlich dieses ganze register da rausschmeißen hier drinnen registern
wobei das nicht wirklich red safe ist was ich da fabriziere oder doch mit dem in doch
mit dem in sollte das eigentlich gehen so was wird funktionieren da müsste ich jetzt
aber auch hier noch die die modifier keys übergeben das wird ganz schön lang ich glaube
auch nicht dass es red safe ist ne das wobei wollte ich sagen wir schreiben das ja in das
warum ein schnitt ne kann überhaupt nicht sein weil ich müsste ich müsste wenn schon
sowas machen diese quasi locker das würde das würde funktionieren das würde funktionieren
das würde funktionieren aber wer braucht von red safe aber irgendwie gefällt mir das
auch nicht so vielleicht sollten wir wirklich auch wenn wir uns über die java klassennamen
immer lustig machen vielleicht sollten wir wirklich sowas wieder wie den hotkey mannager
factory oder sowas machen ja thera fox wofür gibt es exceptions ist komplett aufgerätet
der gutes exception handling hat braucht kein red safe code easy wenn das hier wenn du
so zeug hier einer mitschneidet und mal irgendwie so zeigt seine lehrer oder so so nach dem
motto kommt man ja aber der typ hat gesagt das ist halt voll aus dem context gerissen
ich bin gerade wirklich meine kreativität bewegt sich wirklich auf negativen niveau
gerade es ist ganz schlimm permanent permanent dieser zustand quasi
den socket wieder klaus ich würde sowas auch nicht raushauen
wenn ich einen stund an abteilen aber abteilen ich bin erst über eine stunde und ich komme
fast mit dem jacht und so war ich bin ich weiß auch nicht älter übelst weil sie den sleeper
ist auch nicht okay aber ganz kurz konzentrieren also vielleicht sollten wir wirklich sowas
machen quasi sowas in der richtung dass wir sagen nennen wir es nennen wir es mal da kriegen
wir einen händler ja ok mache ich
warte mal wie ging das ist das nicht so hat man wie ging das noch mal
so ging das ich bin aber nicht auch mal das an der stelle
ich habe zu wenig gestreben im december ich muss jetzt glaube ich nur heute morgen streben
dann darf ich partner bewerbung machen weiß gar nicht ob man das braucht also ich vermute
mal dass man das braucht weil es das gibt ja aber ich hätte jetzt eigentlich damit
gerechnet dass das so quasi in einem taktszyklus irgendwie so durch ist so ein increment so
dass man da eigentlich überhaupt nichts multithread fällen kann wäre ich jetzt eigentlich so
ausgegangen aber man weiß ja nie so genau ja
die musik muss man kurz überspringen besser
genau der increment manager genehmigt das
übrigens ich habe mir denks runtergeladen in search and see sandstorm
heute unbedingt mal spiel aber nicht on stream da muss ich konzentrieren weil ich habe mir
ein paar reviews durchgelesen und gestern meint ja auch im stream einer das könnte was für
mich sein so eine mischung aus cs und battlefield muss ich mir mal angucken und weil die reviews
sind echt gut es wird rumgeflämt es wird rumgeflämt nicht da rude es wird rumgeflämt
dass das game eine scheiß performance hat das ist aber auch das einzig schlechte was
man so über das gelb hieß das hat eine kack performance das ist das ist im prinzip so die
ganzen negativ comments allerdings wenn das halt auf einem 8700k mit einer 1080 ti nicht
richtig läuft dann weiß ja das leute ich glaube ich progas heute nicht weiter ich bin echt
komplett im arsch und ich weiß nicht warum irgendwie zu müde ich glaube ich wäre echt
zu müde heute die also eins muss man sagen was die bei diesem epic music mix nicht hinkriegen
ist dass die musik lautstärke ungefähr gleich ist also mir könnte den ding irgendwie so
ein händel übergeben und dann könnte man irgendwie hier drin sagen und würde fast
sagen das ist die ja gut aber wenn das wenn das wenn das händel dann und das auch alles
nicht fängt an wie wieder flucht der karibik soundtrack oder
dass wir irgendwie so was hier machen und was man dann quasi hier sagen oder sowas
das gibt es ja doch das ist doch bestimmt wenn aus forms schon eingebaut ki das gibt
es doch das müssen wir doch gar nicht selbst definieren das ist doch garantiert schon eingebaut
haben wir hier irgendwie key down key event angst guck mal wie das heißt was da drin ist
kies ja einfach nur kies kies dann müssen wir gar nicht selbst machen ki so viel besser
wäre der ram nichts für dich warte mal guckst du mir an das ist jetzt nicht den hier ernst
oder das ist jetzt nicht den hier ernst ich meine das ist eh nur fake alter das ist wirklich
big brain ram weil das hier ist klasse oder das war es aus wie es scheint das ist klasse
wo die leds leuchten gehe ich mal von aus das ist überhaupt led das ist überhaupt led
mit bestimmtes led dann hätte ich auch sein können dass einfach klasse ist ohne was drunter
was wir jetzt mal angucken wie das in action aussieht die sieht fast aus wie meine bloß
also ich habe ja ich habe ja den ram aber halt nicht die die royal diamond edition ja
ich habe nur die normalen ich habe nur den hier ich gehe mal davon aus dass der hier
quasi der hier ist dass hier quasi anstatt anstatt dem plastik halt so komisches klasse
drin ist es doch genau das gleiche oder bloß dass hier klasse ist anstatt den plastik oder
nicht klasse halt plastik ist hier ein gebrösel das plastik ich meine ich finde eigentlich
dass es ganz cool aussieht es ist halt schon massiv sinnlos ja huge huge waist irgendwie
aber es ist schon ganz cool und royal ist es wahrscheinlich weil es gold ist ram ist
in letzter zeit wieder ein bisschen billiger geworden was ist das für ram ddr 4 320 3200
ich glaube ich glaube ram ist in letzter zeit genau noch ist es genau ist es ja ist es auf
jeden fall ich glaube geizhals wird die webseite nie moderner machen ich meine es ist irgendwo
verschenktes potential weil die seite auf mobile nicht gescheit funktioniert also man
kann sie benutzen aber eine schöne schöne mobile experience ist was anderes man müsste
ja gar nicht viel machen an der seite zum beispiel dieses zeug hier besser klickbar
machen auf mobile aber zum beispiel es hätte es würde auch nicht schaden wenn man quasi
in der in der smartphone ansicht wenn wenn die leiste quasi ein menü wird oder so ansonsten
kann man ja alles so lassen das funktioniert ja ok guck mal mal was ist das billigste ram
den man gerade kriegt weil ich brauche ja noch also ein 4g könnte ich noch brauchen das
ist auch kein notebook ram ne ne ja so 24 99 kann ich mir nicht mit leben auch direkt
moment ist
kann man nicht sagen die geschwindigkeit was da ne das ein proma eins proma das egal ob
sagt die f4 habt ihr kennt ihr ein schönes kleines itx gehäuse da muss nichts reinpassen
außer das mainboard eine pci express karte und der ssd sollte sollte wirklich schön
schön klein sein dass ich auch immer ein rack stellen kann das sind auch 4 he frei drinne
also ich will sie nicht verbauen ich reiche wenn ich reinstellen kann irgendwas kleines
billiges also für die kiste die wir letztens eingerichtet haben aber ich muss sagen die
rampreise sind wirklich in ordnung mittlerweile wenn man sich überlegt von 41 euro runter
irgendwie auf 25 das ist in ordnung ich meine ich meine wirklich nur gehäuse ich meine
kein fertigen fertigen rechner das board habe ich ja schon hier ich habe hier so ein sd
da das ding habe ich mir wohl für den pc express drauf also ganz kleines passiv gekühlte
sport mit ein paar sata anschlüsse und pci express drauf das reicht was bitt phoenix
prodigy prodigy
das ist ein bisschen hoch wo stehen da die die abmaße das ist glaube ich zu hoch wobei
das hinlegt könnte das ganz gut funktionieren das ist gut das ist nice abmaße abmaße was
das letzte paar jahre gehäuse von den immer aber da muss man gucken wie sind die abmaße
von dem ding also es ist wenn man es hinlegt ist es ist 40 zentimeter ungefähr 40 zentimeter
breit wenn man das hinlegt weil hingestellt kriege ich glaube ich nicht
wie viel ist eine höhen einheit in zentimeter ein drei viertel inches okay nach 45 45 zentimeter
nicht 45 zentimeter 44 millimeter ja komm mal stells millimeter ich hab das ich hab das
halt hier so als nicht als als als als als komm mal ein bisschen hoch ich meine das ist
so passt irgendwie nicht so okay also sagen wir mal 45 45 millimeter also 4,5 4,5 zentimeter
so 4,5 mal 4 18 dann passt das nämlich so nicht bei mir rein auf gar keinen fall ich
hab selbst wenn ich das doppelte höhen im rack frei hätte aber es würde aber so wird
es reinpassen na ja das ist gut 12 x 5 meter so würde es reinpassen also solid state drive
17 354 so würde das reinpassen
das ist auch schön klein also was ich an dem her ganz gut finde ich an dem an dem anderen
also das gefällt mir prinzipiell eigentlich ganz gut das hat auch eine das hat auch eine
aufwärts schacht muss halt sagen hingelegt ist halt dass links und rechts voll verschenkt
letztendlich also das habe ich dann 18 zentimeter 18 zentimeter
dann würde das auch nicht passen warte mal ich muss mal kurz in mein rack gucken wie
viel platz ich da wirklich habe drinne
ich könnte die usw theoretisch eins runter machen dann habe ich 5 e frei warum holt ihr
nicht einfach ein rackmount gehäuse weil ich was billiges haben will außerdem muss das
nicht unbedingt im rack hängen das reicht wenn es da unten drin ist ich will irgendwas
billiges haben was ist chat was mit euch los um legt ihr euch ab
ja wie dem aus sei die das ich das finde ich aber hier das finde ich ganz schön das muss
ich mir mal speichern ok das passt nicht rein 18 18 zentimeter ist egal wie man es dreht
passt nicht ok wie sieht es mit dem hier aus und das ist auch das ist das ist auch das
passt von der höhe her auf jeden fall das sieht schon so mini aus da passt aber passt
da eine pizzi express rein zeigt mir mal das gehäuse von hinten please ja da braucht man
aber so eine riser card legt doch einfach das mainboard rein das mache ich ja auch gerade
genau das mache ich ja auch gerade es liegt einfach drinne ich ich brauche auch kein gehor ich
brauche kein netzteil ich habe so ein für das teil habe ich so ein teil so was da habe
ich so mini mini netzteil also ich das ist ein gehäuse ich brauche kein gehäuse wo
netzteil rein passt hier passt eh kein netzteil rein kein normales oder in das da nachdem
wie hoch das ist also das finde ich finde ich ganz ein was kostet das
kostet ja mehr als mein rechner nicht ganz
guck mal den den billig rechner in dem wir das was wir letztens zusammen eingerichtet
haben er hat zusammen gekostet ja irgendwie sowas in dem dreh 85 euro fürs fürs mainboard
da ist die cpu schon mit drauf fest fest unter dem dings da irgendwie verbaut und einem
ram noch mal eben 25 euro also 100 euro den rest hatte ich noch ich habe 100 euro quasi
ausgegeben für sie kommt noch mal fast das doppel obendrauf mit dem gehäuse wie hoch
ist das hier abmaße
das könnte reinpassen wenn ich wenn ich das die usw und weil es hätte schon seinen schaden
wenn ich eins finde mit einem laufwerks schacht könnte ich nämlich wenn ich nämlich für
die ssd noch den dings einbauen mit einem schacht was ist das
sieht es das sieht auf jeden fall schon mal billig aus nicht optische medien ich will
in den schachten für die ssd wechselding einbauen da brauchst du 3,5 die 5,25 zoll schacht
dafür ich habe da noch ein paar dinger von also wechselrahmen habe ich lustigerweise
jede menge ja genau so ein hotspot da habe ich lustigerweise jede menge weiß gar nicht
warum ich da so viel von habe eigentlich total useless ja das ist das sieht schön billig
aus was hat das für abmaße ja das ist gut das passt da auf jeden fall rein
guckt mal da würden sogar zwei stück übereinander reinpassen oder tiefe juckt mich nicht breite
passt auch rein so ein rack ist 19 zoll das heißt ein zentimeter passt auf jeden fall
oder du bootest die kiste einfach über ihr ist ja gut aber ich musste ja von irgendwo
booten ich speck bei mir ja gerade ab daheim meine fette 8 core 4he xeon kiste wird ja in
rente geschickt die darf ab und zu noch mal was machen wenn man power braucht aber ansonsten
wird hier abgelöst durch klein kram das ding finde ich ganz gut das ist schön billig
das ist schön billig haben die mal haben den bild haben den bild von dem ding in drinnen
noch mal so in drinnen was hat man in drinnen dann loch vorne das ist einfach nur da oder
es hat keinen tieferen sinn dass da vorne noch drin ist ja und wo macht man jetzt das
mainboard drauf ach da das ist unten oder was hier was ich dann als nass nehme einen
glaub der da ist es nicht dass ich das jetzt durch dann erbringe warte mal ich muss mal
gucken ob es das wirklich nein hc 2 was ja das ding nämlich dann das ist wirklich die
abgespeckte variante da mache ich den 10 10 terabyte platte rein dass das ding kommt
quasi schon mit mit mit dem rahmen für die für die platte dabei es gibt es gibt auch
noch so hässliche dinger zum selbst drucken aber das sieht aus wie 1980 das sieht echt
mega hässlich aus ja so schaut das dann ungefähr aus bloß dass ich die wache ich habe die variante
wo eine 3,5 zoll platte nee kein rate da kommt eine 10 terabyte platte dran und einmal nachts
einmal nachts wird er singt das reicht wie gesagt ich habe absolut den den overkill
zur zeit laufen mit meinem 13 terabyte zfs rate 5 was ist mit ausversicht ist doch ist
doch im prinzip ausfallsicher sicher genug wenn ich das einmal nachts spiegel und wenn
das wenn das verreckt löpsel ich halt eine neue platte dran und kopierst von der back
ab platte wieder drauf dauern zwar halt zwei drei stunden aber ich mein es ist ich will
ja das ding ist aber wirklich ganz gut
60 euro je nachdem wo man wo man man guckt das ist ein acht kerne acht kerne arm
mit vier relativ schnellen cpu kern und vier mittelmäßig schnellen cpu kern das heißt
das ding ist schnell genug gerade so schnell genug dass es quasi verschlüsselt das quasi
verschlüsselt samba also festplatten voll verschlüsselt über samba einen gigabit ungefähr
ausgelastet kriegt das ist ok und es hat noch ein usb vorne weg hat noch ein usb vorne mit
dem ich dann auf die zweite platte spiegeln so sieht das aus im endeffekt das reicht
ja hier vorne kommt die zweite 10 t plattetran an ans usb da ist es usb hier ist die mikro
sd karte das ist so ein mini das ist ich habe es nicht für möglich gehalten dass man sogar
die hälfte von mikro sd karten slot weglassen weglassen kann aber die haben das geschafft
der mikro sd karten slot ist plus halb solange da sind nur die kontakte drin quasi die haben
wirklich an jedem an jedem millimeter gesparte
zumindest da kommt die usb platt das war eine usb 2 aber um mal nachts zu ersunken ist das
kein ding das passt und das ist das ist halt ein übelstes downgrade von meiner jetzigen
kiste aber die ist auch wahnsinnig wahnsinnig
oversized und ich habe mir sogar überlegt meinen krassen 10g switch auszutauschen was
ein bisschen blöd ist weil das irgendwie 500 euro ins sand gesetzt sind deswegen wieder
strebt sie mir noch ein bisschen so
aber es ist im prinzip er wird kaum benutzt ja ich meine ich habe jetzt ich habe die das
nass per 10 geht ran und ich habe meinen desktop mit 10 geht ran und ja ich kann auch relativ
schnell kopieren aber nicht dass ich das jetzt brauchen würde
ach das geht schon das geht schon das geht schon sind wir also der muss initial halt
einmal zünden wobei halt meine 10 also aktuell habe ich von meinem also das ist ja ein quasi
5 aus drei platten im endeffekt ist es nennt sich bei zfs ein bisschen anders und das heißt
bei 13 t platten sind 20 terabyte für das rate die anderen 10 terabyte ist für für
rate parity gedürft
und ich habe davon vielleicht keine ahnung 2 oder 3 t voll das war es das heißt ich ziehe
mir die jetzt auf eine platte drauf oder auf zwei platten
und dann kopiere ich das rüber das heißt ich muss einmal ich muss einmal quasi gigabit
übers netzwerk einmal 3 t kopieren und dann kann er sich nach zünden das reicht das reicht
dicke ja und da sind auch da sind auch drei terabyte ins weiße in zwei drei stunden oder
so irgendwie keine ahnung wie lange das dauerte usb 2 aber es sind auch fertig und dann muss
es ja nachts bloß noch immer einmal erst ein backup machen von der ersten platte und
das der kopiert ja nicht jedes mal jedes mal 10 terabyte der kopiert ja bloß die unterschiede
rüber und das ist ja quasi dann kaum was von nacht zu nacht dauern ein paar minuten
epic powermix das ist dann das ist dann wirklich so ein simples simples easy setup ich bin wieder
strebt mit dem 10 terabyte switch echt noch ein bisschen weil das ding ist so ein geiles
teil aber es frisst halt eigentlich frisst es nur die strom zumal ja dann ich noch nicht
mal über das nass 10 10 g irgendwie halbwegs aus habe ich 10 t gesagt 10 g 10 terabyte
switch easy ja wie wieder strebt es halt irgendwie noch den switch wegzupacken aber ich meine
er bringt mir dann nichts mehr wenn auch nicht mal wenn das nass 10 g hat bringt es auch
nichts wenn ich 10 g am last hopp ist komplett sinnlos gibt es jetzt von mikrotik einen
switch also für alle die 10 g 10 g bock drauf haben daheim es gibt jetzt den richtig guten
10 g switch von mikrotik also auch den günstigen den g switch der da da kriegt ihr für 140
euro oder so kriegt ihr einen 4 port sfp plus und einen 1g kupfer switch das ist wirklich
billig das ist echt huge billig und es hat komplett komplette mikrotik router os gedürnt
drauf kann man auch alles mögliche mit machen wobei man auf also ich würde ich würde da
jetzt auch wenn es geht da ist das router os von mikrotik drauf ich würde damit nicht
allzu viel layer 3 und magic zeug drüber machen aber das ist wirklich gut also das
kann ich wirklich empfehlen das teil vom preis her kostet lasst uns mal gucken achja ihr
müsst ihr müsst euch auch ein paar module kaufen oder ihr holt euch ein direkt attach
kabel aber nicht das hier sondern ein billigeres es gibt von mikrotik auch den relativ günstigen
sfp plus auf kupfer modul also gucken wir mal was das ding kostet ich glaube 140 euro
oder so aber das das lohnt sich wirklich wenn man man 10 g daheim haben will 160 wenn man
guckt wenn man guckt kriegt man zwar wahrscheinlich sogar ein bisschen billiger guckt man mal
ganz als ja der der große was heins ich wollte nicht heins ich wollte geiz als man heiz als
ja mikrotik ist allgemein so mein tipp immer wenn wenn einer was haben die hatten leider
nix zu der zeit wo ich wo ich mir was gekauft habe ich habe mir so ein ubiquiti 10g wird
gekauft mit 12 fsp plus und 4 10 g kopfer parts das ding ist auch übelst geil aber eigentlich
viel zu teuer denke ich 500 euro oder so gekostet und ich benutze es quasi kaum
wo ist denn das switch ja ist er das nee ganz an das er hier gar nicht drin steht doch
der tut hat sich nur verschrieben ja ja also man kriegt man kriegt hier bei alternat 150
euro was hast du für exis point ich habe wild wild gemischt wild gemischt also der main
exis point ist ein ubiquiti ac pro dann habe ich noch den mikrotik so ein klein mikrotik
exis point und noch einen tp link exis point ist wirklich wild wild gemischt gemischt so
das die mikrotik hatten ein modul nen das da oder was das hier die hatten die hatten
ein super billiges das da genau die hatten ein ziemlich günstiges
modul für wurde quasi in den sfp plus slot einen ganz normalen 45 stecker für 10 g ja
der mikrotik switch kann auch zwei netzteile ist richtig gut das ding der kleine auch der
kleine auch der kleine kann auch zwei netzteile die mikrotik dinger sind echt gut also man
könnte zum beispiel sagen man holt sich ja wenn man den kleinen nimmt also mein mainboard
hat ja on board 10 g hier im desktop und könnt ihr jetzt beispielsweise sagen ich hole mir
hier so einen die ich hole mir den mikrotik switch und ich hole mir so ein modul dabei
da bin ich bei irgendwie 200 euro in dem dreh was was preislich dafür extrem gut ist ja
du hast dann du hast quasi sfp so und und attach kabel habe ich ja habe ich ja noch und module
für glasfaser habe ich ja auch noch also ich bräuchte hoffe dass sie da drin laufen wobei
man sagen muss mikrotik ist was die was die module für switcher angeht von der kompatibilität
ja ziemlich gut ubiquiti verkacken ist da immer guck mal gibt sogar noch billiger hier 54
euro da bin ich mit ziemlich genau mit ziemlich genau 200 euro dabei ich meine das ist wirklich
das ist unglaublich billig weil es braucht kaum einer 12 ports und vier ports kopfer
das brauchen die wenigsten also ich habe ja aktuell ich habe mir dieses ding hier geholt
vor vor zwei jahren oder so und wie viel kostet es mittlerweile eigentlich ok es ist es ist
wieder ein bisschen günstiger geworden so das ist den switch habe ich aktuell den vielleicht
auch mal in groß ohne und das ist halt auch das ist massive overkill 12 ports sfp plus
und vier kopfer ports ich habe es mir da ich habe mir das teil damals geholt weil es nichts
vergleichbares gab und es der einzig halbwegs erschwingliche war wenn man wenn man quasi
nach was gesucht hat was mehr als 2 10 g ports hatte und du brauchst mehr als 2 10 g ports
so ein switch mit nur 2 10 g ports ist relativ sinnlos weil da kannst du quasi du kannst
es nicht vervielfältigen du kannst kannst dein server dranstecken du kannst ein klein
dranstecken gut ist sobald du was nächstes dranstecken willst kannst vergessen also brauchst
eigentlich dass du es quasi dass du die ports vermehren kannst du brauchst eigentlich mindestens
drei ports aber deswegen habe ich mir das ding damals geholt und das ding ist auch
ein echt geiler switch das ist wirklich top und für den preis gibt es glaube ich immer
noch nichts vergleichbares wenn man wenn man auf wenn man nach kopfer ports guckt wobei
man halt sagen muss dadurch dass mikroticket so ein günstiges so ein günstiges kopfer
modul hat ist es gar nicht mehr so wild weil meistens brauchst du ja gar nicht so viel
wenn du überhaupt wenn du überhaupt kopfer ports brauchst bei 10 g ist kopfer eigentlich
eher das ungewöhnliche ja es kennt zwar jeder die rj 45 stecker und jeder hat hat
es halt hat halt so ein teil daheim stehen aber im 10 g bereich ist eigentlich oh fuck
ein mikro runtergefallen mein verlängerungsteil im 10 g bereich ist eigentlich lange zeit
so gewesen dass du hauptsächlich glasfaser hattest und die module sind halt auch billiger
naja also der switch ist immer noch preislich ziemlich gut wenn man halt das braucht 12
ports und 4 ports kopfer 10 g mikrotik hat soweit ich weiß auch nichts mit kopfer ports
allerdings haben die halt diesen adapter und ich war mir halt echt schon am überlegen
ich glaube das ding ist sogar passiv gekühlt oder ich glaube das ding ist sogar passiv
gekühlt und hat halt die geile mikrotik firmen ja die mikrotik firmen ist wirklich super
als es heißt quasi linux drunter also ganz ganz tief unter der haube aber du hast halt
in den web frontend mit dem du wirklich jeden scheiß machen kannst fast fast also gibt fast
nichts was du nicht machen kannst und lässt sich für das dass es quasi profi funktionen
sind eigentlich auch ganz gut bedienen also wer sich wer sich schon mal mit cisco kommando
zeile rumschlagen musste die irgendwo ganz logisch ist wenn man sich dran gewöhnt hat
ja aber so ein web frontend ist schon ist ist bei mikrotik finde ich schon angenehmer zu
bedienen da was ich bei mikrotik witzig finde viele leute auf amazon die sich also mikrotik
router kaufen die ja es ist dr magic es kann gut sein wenn man das jeden tag macht das
ist bestimmt die leute die sich halt auf amazon dann so mikrotik dingen hier kaufen die sind
übelst am flamen so nach dem oder checkt man überhaupt nicht in der oberfläche und viel
zu überladen und sonst was soll das halt mal mit mit wirklich profi switches vergleichen
oder wo das halt wirklich gelernt haben muss dass es funktioniert
das ist auch lustig die wenigsten leute wissen dass eigentlich ios das cisco betriebssystem
war früher die meisten leute ist ios das apple ding die sich ja auch erst gekauft haben die
rechte da dran ich weiß was das gekostet hat ja aber die mikrotik tinger sind wirklich
gut juniper habe schon nie verwendet weiß ich nicht ich bin ja ich habe mich mache
bei uns quasi kein netzwerkzeug das heißt ich habe jetzt nicht so die tägliche erfahrung
mit aber ich habe ein paar mikrotik sachen hier und ist es echt sehr sehr nice
das ist sehr nice guck hier sieht man auch hast du zwei
kann der poe ich wüsste zwar nicht wie man das über glasfaser machen soll aber warum
bis 57 der auf dem kupfer port poe was auf mikrotik hat glasfaser poe erfunden jetzt
ne hat er nicht na der hat auf dem kupfer poe input achso
er hat poe input deswegen verträgt er so viel den kannst du den kannst du den switch kannst
über poe betreiben was was eigentlich auch ganz cool ist wenn du schon netzwerkverkabelung
hast ja das ding gefällt mir echt gut ich mich mich juckt in den fingern mir so ein
zahl zu bestellen aber wozu bald habe ich noch nicht mal mehr nass was 10g kann warum
sollte ich die 10g switch hinstellen total bescheuert max total bescheuert ich habe nichts
was auch nur einer 10g kann und ich will mir noch einen cg switch kaufen passive exile
genau wir stecken ein paar exile orbs in den in den switch rein dann läuft er ja das
ist auch das problem was ich habe einfach ums zu haben ja ich meine der witz ist ja
es ist ne ne das mache ich jetzt total bescheuert der witz ist ja ich brauche auf jeden fall
ich muss noch einen weiteren normalen 24 port oder so gigabit daneben stellen weil die
port halt nicht reicht das heißt es ist es ist einfach nur useless
ne bestellt mich was hat was hat mikrotik eigentlich haben die denn für günstige
switche ein paar mehr gigabit ports
eine 400 mega cpu ist aber schau ob sie outdated
was sehr erst 328 ja das ist die fette das die fette variante auch mit
der ist aber wahrscheinlich nicht mehr passiv gekühlt denke immer
das ist der ist auch neu der ist der muss auch neu sein also irgendwie dieses jahr
der kann den kann es auch nicht so lange geben ja guck mal hier haben sie geschrieben im april
2018 dass es noch nicht geliefert wurde ja ich will ich will eigentlich gar kein 10g
ich ich bin ja gerade dabei 10g bei mir abzuschaffen ich brauche ich will ich brauche
gar kein cg ich finde ich finde die teile eigentlich bräuchte ich einfach die bräuchte
eigentlich einfach nur noch einen ordentlichen
bei brauche ich das auch nicht ich kann da auch mal billig tp link verwenden ist total
sinnlos ja ich habe hier meinen 5 port mikrotik router der demnächst mein pf sens zeug ablöst
weil halt die kiste weg kommt da kommt dann eben an den port fürs interne netzwerk kommt
da billige tp linkswitch dran und gut ist ich muss ja nicht unbedingt jetzt einfach nur
um es zu haben den scheiß kaufen
nee ubi quits die switche will ich mir nicht mehr holen
ich hab mich zu sehr an die mikrotik firmware jetzt gewöhnt und wie geil das ist was man
mit alles machen kann ich finde es auch ein bisschen blöd ich habe mir ich habe ja diesen
wie gesagt ich habe ja den den diesen ubi quits die 10g switch der ist ganz gut vom
web interface her der hat kann zwar nur switching beschichten also nicht so wie mikrotik aber
reicht ja auch der hat wegen ordentliches web interface was mir voll auf den sack geht
ist für den access point dass die dass die ubi quits die access points kein web interface
haben das ist totaler Mist du musst immer noch irgendwie so einen irgendwie den docker
container unify oder sowas laufen lassen das ist zum kotzen
ich meine verstehe es gar nicht warum kann man nicht den web interface auf den access
point machen ok doch ich verstehe es die wollen ja explizit dass du das über dieses unify
zeug managt das ja ich verstehe es schon irgendwie aber es nervt mich
was weiß ubi quits die oder irgendwie so aus weiß ich nicht weil ich weiß ubi quits ich
bin ja der ist der ist aber echt auch ganz leise hier das ist und deswegen ist das cool
dass das mikrotik jetzt diesen moment das sind quatsch das sind das sind jetzt ein
g brauche ich schon kupfer stels habe ich gar nicht richtig geguckt
an die nicht in neun eins der da das der neue genau das der 16 port sfp plus fette neue
ja auch nicht mehr aus der passiv ne das nicht passiv
ich hole mir nix neues eigentlich bescheuert aber auf jeden fall wenn man sowas sucht mikrotik
beste ist einfach so ja die haben dr magic die haben es die haben ssh zugang auf diesen
access points aber da kannst du nur sehr beschränkt was drüber drauf machen auf dem access point
der ssh zugang ist im prinzip eigentlich nur dafür da falls es irgendwie rum backt dass
man das ding über ssh an dem an dem unify controller richtig registriert es gibt ein
paar befehle die man also man kann auch ein paar dinge sonst machen aber du findest beispielsweise
auch nirgendwo irgendwie eine offizielle beschreibung was man alles mitmachen kann
es ist also ist auf jeden fall sehr beschränkt der kommando zeilen zugang auf diesem equity
access points ja das geht mir ein bisschen auf den keks das die kann er das dass man
immer diesen komischen unify controller laufen lassen muss ich meine ich komme irgendwie
blöd vor für einen access point in unify controller laufen zu lassen ja wenn ich wenigstens
ja noch in unify switch gekauft hätte hätte ich allerdings mein switch und den access point
in unify controller machen können aber so ist es irgendwie sieht so ein bisschen mickrig
aus wie sind wir eigentlich von programmier auf
netzwerkswitches gekommen weil ich heute absolut programmier brainlag hab ja über die app
ist ja noch schlimmer ich hab's ich hab's eingerichtet glaube ich über die app der
hat irgendwie ein netzwerk gestartet hat ohne verschlüsselung und sowas die app war jetzt
auch nicht so dabei seit letzter schluss warum hat das ding nicht einfach den webinterface
wie jedes andere ding auch das verstehe ich nicht ich meine bei dem switch kriegen sie
es doch auch hin
du brauchst den controller nicht wenn eingerichtet hast das ist richtig aber wenn du was ändern
willst und du kannst auch gar nicht alles über die app ändern kann man oder kann man zum
beispiel kann man wie landsettings über die app machen oder client isolation isolation
zeug über die app wahrscheinlich nicht deswegen du brauchst im endeffekt so ein komisches
unify ding das finde ich halt kacke kennst du das spiel ringo philisium ja kenne ich
hab ich vom lost ab und zu mal gesehen ich vertausche das nicht ich hab doch so ein teil
brauchst dass du diesen access point ordentlich verwenden kannst brauchst du so einen so einen
so einen unify entweder docker container vm oder oder diesen komischen offiziellen stick
von denen und das finde ich ja ich weiß dass der kein richtiges webinterface hat das finde
ich ja gerade blöd der der switch von denen den ich habe der hat ein richtiges webinterface
das ist aber auch kein aus der unify reihe das ist ein edge switch der die haben den
webinterface doch da da da hat ein ordentliches webinterface was macht eigentlich das grüne
lambda das ist eine konsole ordentliche konsole für windows weil das weil die normale windows
so scheiße ist leider gibt es kein hardtop oder sowas da
ist der baul ist das werbung
das hältst du eigentlich von dem keine werbung da meinst du du meinst ich klick mal drauf
wo
mega irritierend ist, ne?
Ich bin eigentlich kein Fan von allem, was quasi den Browser sich anders verhalten lässt, als man gewöhnt ist.
Aber an sich finde ich, also irgendwo finde ich das cool, ja?
Ja gut, das hakliche ist halt, weil die wahrscheinlich nur irgendwie ein paar Fotos gemacht haben.
Wenn die da jetzt irgendwie 300 Fotos gemacht hätten, dann ginge das wahrscheinlich auch super, super weich.
Aber von der Idee her finde ich das cool.
Was hältst du eigentlich von dem da? Ich glaube, ich glaube das ist ein altes Board.
Ja, oder? Das ist ein neues Board. Muss ich jetzt gerade mal gucken.
Ne, das sind die Alten, da wünsche ich mir keinen mehr kaufen. Ich glaube das sind die Alten.
Wenn ich jetzt nicht total falsch liege.
Das sind jetzt die Alten mit der ollen CPU drinne, die es irgendwie schon seit 2008 oder so gibt.
Ja, guck mal.
Von 2011 oder so ist das. Die wünsche ich mir nicht mehr holen.
Jetzt würde mir Windows Shell geflammt haben. Die Windows Shell sackt ja auch.
Dora, kennst du die neuen, dass ihr Release Date in letzter Zeit gewesen ist und weil sie meistens irgendwie 800 plus Megahertz CPUs haben.
Guck mal, sogar mein billig, mein billig 5-Port Router, wie die Cisco Leute gerne sagen, sogar der hat 800 Megahertz CPU.
Und ich glaube, ich glaube das ist auch ein bisschen neuere Baureihe CPU technisch.
Das ist für mich eh so der Geheimtipp schlechthin, das Teil.
PFSense, ich habe ja zur Zeit PFSense habe ich zur Zeit, aber das muss ja weg, weil ich ja die fette 4HE Kiste wegwerfe.
Nee, ich werfe sie nicht weg, ich schalte sie einfach aus, wegwerfen wäre vielleicht ein bisschen Overkill.
Ansonsten bin ich mit PFSense eigentlich recht zufrieden.
Wobei man ja sagen muss, das nimmt sich eigentlich nicht viel. Du kannst prinzipiell beim MikroTik im Webinterface noch ein bisschen mehr machen.
Sogar noch ein bisschen viel mehr, aber dafür ist die Bedienung auch eine ganze Ecke umständlicher als im PFSense Frontend.
Und was halt auch so ein bisschen doof ist, ich finde es einfach Routing und Geduldens auf x86-Chart wäre in der heutigen Zeit überhaupt kein Problem.
Aber letztendlich der Witz ist halt, wenn man das irgendwie vergleichen könnte, mir fällt jetzt kein Weg ein das ordentlich zu vergleichen, ich könnte wetten.
Performance-mäßig, wenn du hier ordentlich was drüber haust über jeden Port, wird wahrscheinlich so ein 800MHz MikroTik Ding irgendwie einen 4-Kern i7 Outperform, was rein das Pakete hin und her schubsen angeht.
Router hat ein Professor immer gesagt, PowerShell finde ich gut, außer dass ich Windows überhaupt nicht mag, finde ich viele Sachen, die Microsoft in letzter Zeit so macht gar nicht schlecht.
Also Microsoft muss man gar nicht mal so sehr haten, Windows sagt halt immer noch ein bisschen.
Nortel-Switch war ich noch nie, habe ich mich noch nie eingeloggt auf sowas, habe ich überhaupt nichts zu sagen.
Ich glaube das exotischste, wo ich mal drauf eingeloggt war, war mal so ein Quanta, wie heißen die Dinge, LB, so ein Helikopter-Switch.
Guck mal, weil er ein Video hat mit der Lautstärke. Guck mal, die moden alle ihre Lüfter vom Switch.
Genau so wie der Hubschrauber.
Genau so hört sich die Dinge an. Ja, endlich ein vernünftiger Arcade-Manager für Windows wäre was.
Was ich ganz gut finde, ist nur für Entwickler-Zeug ist der hier. Der Scoop, den finde ich ganz gut. Der ist allerdings hauptsächlich für Entwickler-Sachen gedacht. Ich weiß immer noch nicht, warum ich Node.js auf Windows inszeniert habe. Hab ich mich das letzte Mal schon gefragt.
Er installiert dann lokal in das User-Home-Directory. Das ist jetzt nicht sinnvoll für viele oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen. Aber den finde ich gut.
Da ist auch mittlerweile relativ viel Zeug drin. Wie gesagt, wenn man Entwickler-Zeug sucht. Also wenn man eine aktuelle Node.js-Version sucht, kann man es da draus ganz gut installieren. Für NPM, ja das kann sein, aber wozu brauche ich NPM hier drauf?
Wisst ihr, brauche ich gar nicht. Ich weiß nicht, wozu ich Node.js installiert habe. Keine Ahnung. Man weiß es nicht.
PowerShell finde ich aber auch eine ganz gute Sache. Windows hat ein bisschen das Problem, dass die halt immer noch nicht geschafft haben, ein gescheites Terminal mit zu liefern.
Dieses PowerShell Ding, das ist ja am Ende das CMD-Fenster in blau. Was anderes ist es hier eigentlich nicht. Und du kannst es irgendwie re-sizen ordentlich, aber was anderes ist es nicht. Es ist genauso kacke.
Das ist wirklich, du kriegst Anfälle, wenn du ein ordentliches Niedungsterminal gewöhnt bist oder auch unter Mac was ordentlich inszeniert hast und dann diesen Krempel hier verwenden musst, dann gibst du wirklich Zustände.
Sind wir aber echt vom Thema abgekommen. Wir machen jetzt schon gefühlt 1,5 Stunden sinnlos Lava-Stells.
Wenn du Windows nicht magst, warum verwendest du dann Linux in einer VMS und andersherum? Weil sich so rum besser integrieren lässt. Also es ist einfacher Linux in Windows einzubilden als Windows in Linux.
Ich meine, ich mache ja hauptsächlich Gaming-YouTube-Zeug. Das habt ihr jetzt alle nicht gehört. Ich habe in letzter Zeit ja recht wenig gemacht, aber eigentlich mache ich Gaming-YouTube-Zeug und Spiele und Audio-Video-Kram.
Das ist halt was, wo ich sagen muss, da sind wir bei Linux leider noch nicht da, wo ich es gerne hätte. Sobald das der Fall ist, werde ich mir auch kein Windows mehr installieren.
YouTube in 2K18. Die Musik geht wieder, als würde jetzt voll die epischen Sachen hier passieren.
Wenn einer einen ordentlichen Router für daheim sucht und er auch wirklich einen Router braucht, keinen Fritzbox-Ersatz wohlgemerkt, das Ding ist echt preisleistungsmäßig das beste, was man sich holen kann.
Ich habe sogar mittlerweile einen Mikrotik-Access-Point mit Router-OS hinter meiner Klingel eingebaut. Wegen PoE.
Die Mikrotik hat wirklich für alles was. So, guck dieses kleine Teil hier.
Exempfehlung, ja, das Ding ist wirklich preisleitendes Firm Office. Das ist es glaube ich, das da. Das ist übelst nice, das ist übelst geil, was man kriegt für 45 Euro.
Das ist ein Access-Point mit 2 Netzwerk-Ports. Den Router kannst du selbst, wenn du willst, per PoE betreiben.
Also Router-Access-Point und er hat PoE-Out und er hat USB. Das ist ein absolutes Multitalent-Ding. Das ist wirklich, und das für 45 Euro, das ist mega geil.
Wenn man halt genau sowas braucht. Ich habe zum Beispiel was gesucht, was hinter meine Klingel passt, weil ich will eine neue Gegensprechanlage vorne hin machen.
Und die muss ich halt irgendwie anschließen. Die hat eine Netzwerk-Stecker dran und das heißt ich muss irgendwie die Gegensprechanlage bzw. das ist so eine Kamera-Gegensprechanlage-Hybrid-Ding, das muss ich halt netzwerkmäßig anschließen.
Und das Problem war, wir hatten keinen, ich zeige es euch mal für die, die meisten haben es wahrscheinlich schon gesehen, ich zeige es euch aber nochmal auf Twitter.
Und das Problem bei mir war, dass ich halt kein Kabel mehr durchlegen kann vom, ey ich lege es mir den Chat klein durch, mit meinem Klingel, da ist es doch, da ist es.
Ja und das Problem war, ich konnte keine Kabel mehr durchlegen vom Keller zur Klingel, weil in weißer Voraussicht keiner Schächte oder keiner Schläuche verlegt hat.
Und ich habe es jetzt so gemacht, ich habe, also es liegt noch, das geht hier alles rein, es kommt hier oben irgendwo raus, also das hängt jetzt hier nur raus beim Einbau, genau Leerrohre.
Und ich habe es jetzt so gemacht, hier vorne ist ja schon so eine Gegensprechanlage dran, so eine Blackmagic-Siedel-Gegensprechanlage, wo keiner weiß, wie sie genau funktioniert.
Und hier neben, hier neben kommt dann die neue dran, die braucht halt Netzwerkkabel, das da, was dann, das was hier hängt quasi, das kommt dann an die, an die neue, neue Gegensprechanlage dran.
Und ich hatte halt das Glück, dass es lag halt ein Kabel, lag halt von dieser Gegensprechanlage im Keller und ich hatte Glück, es sind glaube ich noch, drei Adern sind frei, drei Adern waren auch frei in der, in dem Kabel.
Und dann habe ich es so gemacht, ich habe einen 12 Volt Netzteil, was ist denn, dieses Ding hier für den, für das PoE, einen 48 Volt 0,5 Ampere Netzteil genommen und innen an diese zwei Adern dran gemacht.
Und draußen, habe ich dann quasi wieder einen Stecker auf der anderen Seite dran gemacht, draußen, weil ich brauche da halt nur zwei Adern für, dieses Ding hier, den PoE-Injector dran gemacht.
Der PoE-Injector geht in den Mikrotik Access Point, der Access Point kann selbst wiederum, der kann per PoE betrieben werden und kann selbst wiederum PoE durchreichen an die Kamera bzw. an die Gegensprechanlage.
Das ist wirklich ein super Gerät und das passt alles in, in das olle Ding rein, was der Opa damals in die Wand gemacht hat.
Jetzt ist voll, ne, der Access Point und der PoE-Injector, jetzt ist voll, jetzt passt da nichts mehr rein.
Ich würde den Hex PoE nehmen, ist halt, ist, aber dieses Gerät ist wirklich krass, das ist echt nice.
Was wäre eigentlich eine gute und günstige Lösung für einen WLAN-Empfänger mit einem Ethernet-Port?
Ja sowas hier, muss ja nicht, muss ja nicht beide Ports verwenden, sowas hier ist top.
Die Mikrotik-Dinger kannst du betreiben in, also die ganzen Mikrotik Access Points kannst du betreiben entweder, die haben eben 5 verschiedene Betriebsmodi.
Die kannst du, die kannst du betreiben mit als Access Point, die kannst du betreiben als Client, die kannst du betreiben als Plutch, die kannst du betreiben als Repeater und irgend so ein Hybrid aus allem.
Also kannst du eigentlich alles mitmachen was du willst und der Access Point hängt bei mir jetzt halt quasi als WLAN-Client drinne im WLAN.
Der verlängert quasi das WLAN für das zur Kamera raus mit halt mit einem Kabel dann.
Der macht dann quasi Kabel zu WLAN.
Hast du nicht Bedenken wegen Feuchtigkeit? Ne.
Nee habe ich nicht, weil das hier die Metallplatte hier vorne, die kommt ja, weil die Kabel kommen ja hier rein, die hängen jetzt ja nur draußen, man sieht es jetzt nicht, die hängen nur so hier unten so ein Stückchen runter.
Die kommen rein und das hier geht an diese andere Gegensprechanlage rein.
Das ist dicht, also das kommt dann, da kommt die Metallplatte vorne wieder drauf hier und wird zugeschraubt oben und unten, also da wird es nicht nass drinne.
Und Kühlung ist eigentlich kein Problem, weil die Dinger werden nicht warm und sie sind eben frei.
Und was auch richtig geil noch ist an dem Ding, also das ist wirklich absolutes Multitalent das Teil, das begeistert mich, als würde mich MikroTik dafür bezahlen.
Das Ding hat noch einen USB-Port, der auch mit Strom versorgt ist. Du kannst einmal diesen Router selbst per USB poweren, wenn du willst.
Dann ballert halt die Sonne drauf, da glaube ich nicht, dass irgendetwas passiert.
Die Dinger sind hinter einer spiegelten Platte, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das problematisch wird, großartig.
Das ist eine spiegelnde Metallplatte davor, da wird es schon warm drin, aber die Dinger, guck mal, die Dinger sind ja ausgelegt auch temperaturmäßig.
Guck mal, von minus 20 bis 70 Grad, da passiert gar nichts. Da passiert nichts.
Minus 20 wird es da auch nicht drinne.
Und das alles für 45 Euro, echt geil.
Ja und was ich noch sagen wollte, ist ja nicht nur, dass das Ding PoE out hat, du kannst das Ding auch alternativ per USB poweren.
Oder, was viel besser ist, wenn du das Ding über PoE powerst oder über das Netzteil,
je nachdem, kannst du selbst noch ein USB-Gerät hier dran anschließen und poweren.
Also, wenn ich ein bisschen dickeres Netzteil anschließen würde an der anderen Seite, also bei unserem Keller,
wobei, nee, ich glaube 5 Ampere ist max über PoE, oder 0,5.
Zumindest je nachdem, wie man es macht, könnte man da sogar zum Beispiel noch einen Raspberry Pi dran stöpseln und das Ding poweren lassen,
aber das wird da nicht schaffen. Das ist ein bisschen eng.
Aber sag mal, so irgendwie anderen kleinen Scheiß per USB poweren kannst du damit auch noch, ohne dass du einen extra Adapter bräuchtest.
Das ist halt echt mega nice, das Ding.
Jo.
Probier mal Git-Bash als CMD-Alternative. Hab ich ja, mehr oder weniger.
Also, ich hab keine Git-Bash, ich hab CMD-er mit halt dieser, mit der eingebauten CMD-er-Bash verschmet, was das ist.
Bin ich eigentlich zufrieden mit.
Und das Problem an Windows ist ja, neben das CMD-sack, die Powerstelle ist ja eigentlich ganz okay,
ist halt das komische Terminal-Programm, das da hier.
Das ist halt, das ist halt kompletten Müll. Kannst immer richtig Copy-Pasten drin.
Deswegen ist CMD-er eigentlich erstmal das Wichtigste, dass man ordentlich Terminal-Programm hat.
Und weil irgendwer mal angefragt hat, wegen günstigem WLAN-Empfänger, also ich geh mal davon aus, du willst quasi sowas im kleinen Modus betreiben,
also sprich, dass du quasi dich im WLAN einloggst und dann sowas für dich quasi Verbindung.
Du willst dich per Kabel anstöpseln und du willst quasi, dass das Ding für dich dann die Verbindung WLAN herstellt.
Du kannst dir auch für 25 Euro, kannst dir die Lite-Variante davon holen.
Die hat dann kein PoE, aber für deine Zwecke reicht sie.
Also wenn du quasi jetzt sagst, ich hab hier nur WLAN und möchte meinen Rechner per Kabel anschließen,
spröpselst du deinen Rechner dran und lässt dich mit dem Ding im WLAN einloggen und gut ist.
Ich mein 25 Euro, da kannst du echt nichts sagen.
Und wenn es zu warm wird im Sommer, wenn es zu warm wird hier drin, da mach ich ein USB, ein 2,50 Euro USB-Ventilator dran.
Und dann ist alles gut.
Ja, gut, ähm, übelst lange Laberstellts gemacht.
2 Stunden 35, wir haben jetzt locker, wir haben jetzt locker über eine Stunde geschwätzt.
Ohne was irgendwie auch nur Ansatzweise zu machen sogar.
Aber ich hab heut eh Progas Brainlag des Todes, ich krieg heut nix auf, nix in den Editor rein.
Das Gehäuse ist glaub ich zu groß gewesen.
Ne, passt nicht rein.
Dieses billige 25 Euro Gehäuse fand ich eigentlich am besten bisher.
Weil es ist billig und es würden sogar 2 Stück aufeinander passen.
Das wäre schon mal ganz gut.
Ich kann zwar keinen Wechsel-Dings-Rahmen rein machen für die SSD, oder? Kann man das? Kann man nicht.
Oh, die haben Videos dazu.
Was genau macht der da? Was hat das mit dem Gehäuse zu tun? Nix, oder?
Die Gehäuse kauft, ach ne, das ist nur was, was mit Gehäusen zu tun hat.
Der D-Lan ist auch für mich nur die letzte Lösung, wenn sonst nix mehr geht.
Die Musik ist fertig.
Da haben wir noch mehr Epic.
Wann hast du die Manjaro vor allem eingerichtet? Oh, das ist ja fast schon ein Jahr her, oder so.
Du kannst aber beim Sebaro im Archiv gucken, der hat das irgendwo.
Sebaro hat ja ein Archiv gemacht, mit neuem Domain jetzt.
Äh, nein.
So, richtig, da hast du hier irgendwo ein Archiv oben.
Und das sind alle Streams.
Ich glaube, das update ich ab und zu, aber zumindest die alten Streams sind alle dabei.
Manjaro.
Am 18.01.2017.
Und normalerweise sollte er das dann auch abspielen, wenn man da draufklickt.
Geht mir da Musik jetzt gerade aber.
Ja, guck, da, Archiv.
Der Sebaro hat's drauf in der Richtung, sehr nice.
Kann man sich alte Streams angucken, wenn man will.
So, ich bin gerade beim Thema Datenschutzerklärungen. Kennt ihr den Browser Addon? Ich such sowas schon die ganze Zeit.
Also quasi ein DSGVO Acceptor oder sowas.
Browser Plugin, gibt's sowas?
Also ich suche keinen Browser Plugin für meinen Datenschutz, ich suche einen Browser Plugin, was mir die DSGVO Popups wegmacht.
Also ich suche quasi einen Popup Datenschutz Blocker.
Ach, die haben einen Filter, das ist cool.
Echt, zeig mal her.
Options.
Und das, ich hab, ich stell da so selten was ein drin.
Fanboy.
Ich muss oben bei Filterlist auf Plus drücken.
Wo?
Da?
Ach, hier.
Ach, hier, guck mal, da.
Nee, das Fanboy...
Was da?
Kommt mit irgendeinem Form raus.
Und das Block, das probieren wir mal aus.
Gehen wir mal auf irgendeine Seite, die Datenschutzgedöns hat.
Ja super, jetzt find ich keine.
Reddit hat so ein Gedöns doch, ne?
Warum krieg ich jetzt keine Popups mehr?
Wir brauchen eine Seite, die sicher so ein komisches Popup hat.
Das hat doch fast jede Seite mittlerweile, was?
Wird das schon geplockt vielleicht?
Ah, bei Gunnar war da eine Einblendung.
Ach hier, genau, ja, ich hab's verstanden.
So, und was?
Und wenn man das jetzt einschaltet, dann...
Tatsächlich?
Oh, wie nice.
Was der mit den Cookies macht, ist mir wurscht.
Plänen oder zustimmen, ist mir vollkommen egal.
Oracle, ja, bam.
Tatsächlich, oh, das ist cool.
Das ist, dazu kann ich nur sagen.
Moment.
So, Bamplocker, also nein.
Datenschutz-Spamplocker.
Ihh.
Oh, da fällt mir, da fällt mir ein.
Das ist so eine Sache, die ich auch mal machen wollte.
Ich wollte mal in Stream Stellenanzeige Review machen,
was da teilweise für Dinger drinstehen.
So nach dem Motto, was du alles können sollst und so.
Wo das war?
Hier, du gehst auf die Settings von Uplock
und dann klickst du hier oben auf das Plus.
Wo hab ich das gerade gemacht?
Und suchst nach Panboy.
Dann machst du den nächsten rein und dann war es weg.
Genau, Wikia, Wikia Borderlands oder so, genau.
Aha. Aha.
Der wird noch nicht geplockt.
Allerdings, die werden geplockt.
Okay, na gut, die können auch nicht immer top aktuell sein.
Onplate.
Was soll ich rein machen?
Moment.
Also, die Seite merken wir uns jetzt mal.
Also, was machen wir noch rein?
Fanboy Cookie List, Easy List.
Easy List Germany.
Eats List.
Bam, apply.
Nee, immer noch nicht.
Was passiert eigentlich, wenn man auf Reject klickt?
Leitet es einen auf der anderen Seite um?
Nö, geht einfach zu.
Wollte Rejecten.
Dann muss ich auch die Easy List und die Cookie List wieder rausnehmen.
Das stimmt.
Das müsste man wahrscheinlich aus der Apply Settings haben sie doch gemacht.
Oder habe ich vergessen beim raus?
Doch, ist weg.
Ist weg wieder.
Extra Cookie Son tracking.
Ich weiß das Zeug eh am Zimmer weg.
Da habe ich andere Bedenken im Internet.
Und ihr wisst, dass ich niemand bin, der sagt, ja, ich habe nichts zu verbergen.
Und es ist egal, ob ich getrackt werde und sonst was.
Aber Cookies jucken mich wirklich nett.
Zumal ich das eh ab und zu alles wieder wegschmeiße.
So, ich ewig rumgelabert.
Kann man nochmal, für Cookies gibt es gute Erinnerungs.
Bin immer wieder begeistert, wie das Internet ohne Erdblocker aussieht, wenn ich mal muss.
Wenn ich mal das Internet ohne Werbeblocker verwenden muss, da fällt mir immer auf, wie voll das ist.
Und am schlimmsten sind die Seiten, die irgendwelche ATML Elemente so hijacken.
Dann hast du irgendwie so eine Dropdown-Liste und klickst dann da drauf und auf einmal geht eine andere Seite auf oder so.
Immer noch on, ja, eigentlich wollte ich jetzt was essen.
Zumal ich ja heute eh kompletten Brainplokade habe, so was Broggers angeht.
Ich könnte jetzt ja futtern hier.
Muss mich einfach muten.
Auf der anderen Seite, eigentlich haben wir lange genug geschwätzt, oder?
Obbei, auf der anderen Seite haben wir nie lang genug geschwätzt.
Man könnte mal wieder ein Video aufnehmen für YouTube.
Gucken, ob der Fabian geantwortet hat.
Weil ich wollte ja mit dem Fabian dieses Jahr noch mal eine Sache aufnehmen für YouTube.
Dass wir wenigstens zumindest einmal im Jahr ein Video zusammen am Start haben.
Find es gut, dass ich mittlerweile auch ein paar Leute auf Twitch habe, die nicht von YouTube kommen.
Der da.
Der mit eigentlich viel zu vielen Abos, um nichts zu machen.
Ihr kennt mich ja, ne?
Dual Commentaire mit Frazier.
Der da, ja, ja.
Ja, zu Zeiten, als man seinen Channel noch ordentlich customisieren konnte.
Genau wie beim Krieger.
Ja gut, immerhin habe ich noch Views auf meinen, egal, ich will dazu gar nichts sagen.
Es ist bestimmt nicht einfach.
Ich darf dazu aber eh nichts sagen, weil ich mein, ich verkacke es ja auch absichtlich im Endeffekt.
Könnt ihr euch noch letztes Jahr dran erinnern, wo ich mal 1-2 Monate über Weihnachten letztes Jahr auch wieder viele Videos hochgeladen habe.
Hier so Weihnachten rum.
Das hat so gut wieder angefangen.
Ich habe ganz gut Abos gekriegt wieder.
Die Views sind hochgegangen.
Und dann BAM wieder ins nächste Mal gemacht.
Warum habe ich eigentlich Big Shack im Thumbnail drin?
Battlefield 2, 2, 2 plus 2.
Ja, das Server Video ist, haben voll viele Leute geguckt.
Guck mal, 124K Aufrufe haben sich mein REC angeschaut.
Smoke Trees.
Das ist auch out.
Ah, Sniper Elite 4 Promo.
Bisschen sell out gemacht.
Das war das einzige, wo ich letztes Jahr mit YouTube irgendwie mal ordentlich Kohle gemacht habe.
Sell out.
Mit Nvidia Sellout habe ich keine Kohle gemacht.
Da habe ich nur die Hardware gekriegt, was auch schon umgerechnet in Kohle relativ viel ist.
Aber ich mache ja irgendwie kaum was noch.
Das ist schlimm.
Das Hauptproblem ist einfach, dass mir das Game fehlt.
Das ist das Problem.
Und das ist das, warum ich auch keine Motivation habe.
Ich kann ja nicht immer nur auf YouTube über Gott und die Welt labern.
Ich kann nicht 3-, 4-mal die Woche auf YouTube über Gott und die Welt labern.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Und mir fehlt einfach ein Game.
Mir fehlt einfach ein Game, was ich geil finde.
Mach doch Progress Tutorials.
Ja, das kann ich nicht auf dem Channel machen.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Was ich gemerkt habe, dass die Leute am liebsten Battlefield-Gelaber bei mir sehen, wenn ich hier so rumgucke.
Und das, obwohl ich eigentlich die letzten zwei Battlefields überhaupt nicht gespielt habe.
Aber ich sage es auch immer dabei.
Mach doch ein Game im Progress-Stream und spiele es dann selbst auf YouTube.
Das ist absolut, das ist wirklich big brain.
Ich mache mir mein Lieblingsgame selbst und dann kann ich wieder YouTube machen.
Das ist es.
Nur mal ganz davon abgesehen, dass ich kein Game programmieren kann.
Also das Programmieren würde ich ja vielleicht noch hinkriegen.
Vor allem, vor allem wenn wir irgendwie C Sharp Unity oder sowas machen.
Aber die ganzen Feinheiten dabei, da wird es dann schon schwierig.
Und das nächste ist Grafikzeug, das so künstlerisch veranlagt war.
Aber sowas eigentlich bin ich ja überhaupt nicht.
Ich meine, unsere erste DirectX Anwendung ist ja schon mal eine von echt nice.
Die schafft es immerhin ihr das Gift zu rendern mit 4000 FPS, 4500.
Welcher Gift-Player kann das schon mit 4500 FPS pro Sekunde?
Und es ist wichtig, es sind keine FPS, es sind FPS pro Sekunde.
Also die steigern sich wie man sieht, quasi eine FPS Beschleunigung.
Das ist sowas wie Watt pro Sekunde.
Ja, da müsste ich echt wieder mal was machen.
Ich könnte ja mal bei Asus anfragen, wie es aussieht,
ob die für ihren neuen Monitor nicht meinen Gift-Player haben wollen.
Weil ich meine, die müssen ja in ihre 240 Hertz-Monitore mit passendem Demomaterial ausstatten.
Und was ist da besser als der Rare Parent mit 5000 FPS?
Gibt es eigentlich nichts besseres, oder?
Ich glaube, es gibt kein besseres Demomaterial als ein Gift mit 4000 Bildern pro Sekunde.
Das kann gar nicht sein. Scheiß auf 3D-Animationen oder auf irgendwelche Render, Sequenzen, Intros, was auch immer.
Gift-Animationen.
Das ist schneller als die Source-Engine.
Außerdem, wir sind noch sogar besser als Nvidia Ray Tracing.
Ich meine, die machen sich noch Gedanken darüber, ob sich eine Explosion im Auto spiegelt.
Da sind wir schon, da sind wir schon meilenweit vorbei.
Die haben die Explosion schon hinter uns gelassen.
Wir sind quasi komplett ahead.
Und was noch besser ist...
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich die schnell hinkriege.
Was noch besser ist...
Die haben sogar einen V-Sync-Switch.
Bam, V-Sync an.
Zack, V-Sync wieder aus.
Und wir können sogar, um es noch viel, noch viel besser zu machen.
Alter, ich kann nicht schreiben.
Wir können sogar... Ich kann echt nicht tippen gerade.
Wir können sogar...
Oh, jetzt geht es nicht.
Ach so, ja, wenn ich nichts render, geht es nicht.
Oh, was noch viel besser ist, wenn wir einfach das Bild wegmachen.
Guck mal. Ach so.
Ja, wir lassen das Bild hier immer noch rendern.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wir können einfach mal alles wegmachen.
Dann haben wir 50 Millionen FPS oder so.
Nee, es wird nicht schneller.
Ach so, ich sollte vielleicht einfach nicht warten.
Ich bin zu blöd, meine eigene Schleife schneller zu machen.
Wisst ihr, so war es immer schon.
Ach so, das geht nicht schneller, weil ich jedes Mal Bilder kopiere.
Ich wollte eigentlich in der Schleife mal nichts rendern.
Und dann zeigen, dass wir dann 8000 FPS haben oder so.
Aber es funktioniert nicht.
Dann doch lieber den Papagei mit 4000 FPS pro Sekunde.
Ich meine, es ist schon irgendwo ein bisschen armselig, wenn man sich das anguckt,
dass ich es quasi nicht mal geschafft habe.
Wenn man oben die Seite aufmacht, dass die Videos, die ich dieses Jahr gemacht habe,
gefühlt in die, also seit der letzten Welle, seit der letzten Aktivitätswelle.
Also quasi hier.
Ich glaube, das war das letzte Video, wo ich, also ich habe es seit meiner letzten Aktivitätswelle irgendwie geschafft,
so zwei Spalten Videos zu machen.
Nee, nee, noch nicht mal.
Das war, glaube ich, das letzte Video, was ich in dieser Aktivitätswelle gemacht habe.
Und ich habe es dann geschafft, im restlichen Jahr ganze sechs Videos zu machen.
Es war vom Black Ops 4 Reveal, von diesem komischen Battlefield 5 Trailer,
wo der Typ mit dem Katana rumgerannt ist.
Ey, das ist so fail gewesen, dieser Trailer.
Die haben das Marketingtechnisch so krass verschissen.
Wir müssen uns irgendwann auch nochmal den nächsten Financial Report angucken,
was Battlefield anbelangt.
Danach habe ich ein ziemlich cooles Gameplay Black Ops 4 hochgeladen.
Das war echt nice.
Das war so in dem Monat, wo mir Black Ops Spaß gemacht hat.
Das war es.
Easy.
2020 dann Bad Company.
Wie sehr ich mir wünschen würde, dass sie erstens Bad Company machen.
Aber eigentlich, was ich mich noch viel, viel mehr frage ist,
wenn sie denn Bad Company machen, ob sie es irgendwie schaffen,
am Original dran zu bleiben.
Weil da habe ich so meine Zweifel.
Wenn man sich das hier mal anguckt...
Ich habe ja genug Bad Company 2 Videos.
Aber wenn man sich das hier mal anguckt, was Bad Company 2 ausmacht...
War das nicht Port Valdez? Doch, Port Valdez.
Was Bad Company 2 ausgemacht hat.
Dann habe ich so meine Zweifel,
ob sie es jemals auf die Reihe kriegen, mit einem anderen Team,
was hinzukriegen, was quasi sich so spielt.
Und...
Was ist eigentlich aus dem Battle Royale Modus für Battlefield jetzt geworden?
Wo ist der eigentlich?
Royal Firestorm 2019.
Treppe campen mag das Beste.
Warum bleibe ich nicht an der Treppe sitzen? Treppe sitzen ist das Beste.
Wie er wegrennt.
Er hat weggesprayt.
Das war so ein nicees Game.
Auch das Waffenhändling.
Die Maps in Rush.
Das war das Geile.
Beste.
Und hier.
Epilepsische Anfälle.
Das war so nice.
Die Pistolen in dem Game waren auch nice.
Guck mal, das sind aber die übelsten Kacknoobs, gegen die ich da spiele.
Die sind mega schlecht.
Die sind mega schlecht, die checken ja gar nichts.
Das ist ja auf dem PC.
Ist das auf dem PC?
Nein, Xbox.
Ich muss dir sagen, wir machen auch Bad Company 2 auf dem PC.
Was hatte ich denn auf dem PC?
Ich fand das gut auf dem PC.
Ich fand den PC pot nicht schlecht bei Bad Company 2.
Ich mein, es hat sich halt ein bisschen merkwürdig gespielt, dadurch dass man nicht strafen kann und sowas in der Richtung.
Aber das war halt irgendwo schon ein integraler Bestandteil von Bad Company.
Dass man sich nicht hinlegen konnte und dass man halt so ein komisches, scheppes Movement hatte.
So ein geradeaus Movement ohne Strafen.
Ein bisschen Strafen konnte man ja.
Also nur schräg nach vorne konnte man strafen.
Das hat doch irgendwie dazu gehört.
Es hat sich ja langsam angefühlt.
Bad Company 2 war ja überhaupt nicht langsam.
Bad Company 2 hat sich schwerfälliger angefühlt, aber es war eigentlich gar nicht mal so.
Du konntest das teilweise viel geiler spielen mit Sniper vorne rein und mit Quickscope.
Sniper, Quickscope, besser, beste in Bad Company.
SV98, SV98, Quickscope.
Ich wollte Roadkill, ich wollte Roadkill, das hat nicht geklappt.
Was macht der Typ da überhaupt am Spawn?
Ultranices Game.
Ja, und es ist ja mittlerweile so, die haben ja nichts mehr von den ursprünglichen Leuten.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie wirklich gar nichts mehr haben.
Aber die meisten dürften einfach nicht mehr da sein.
Zumal ja das nächste Bad Company auch, also falls das nächste Battlefield.
Denn Bad Company 3 ist, wovon ich ehrlich gesagt so bauchgefühlmäßig ausgehe.
Weil es hat zwar bei den Leaks da nicht alles gestimmt.
Aber die Richtung war sowohl beim World War 1 und beim World War 2 Game ziemlich gut, was da geleakt wurde.
Und deswegen, Bauchgefühl sagt mir das schon, das ist das nächste Battlefield.
Ich hoffe ja, es wäre doch geil, wenn die einfach sagen würden, das kommt schon 2019 raus.
Wenn es dann fertig ist.
Also nicht so nach dem Motto Battlefield 5 spielt sich scheiße, hat sich scheiße verkauft, macht mal schneller Bad Company.
Nee, nee, wenn das Spiel fertig ist.
Aber es wäre halt nice, wenn das dieses Jahr schon fertig wäre.
Also sollte wirklich die Bad Company 3 Ankündigung kommen.
Und es sich auch nur ansatzweise aussehen in den Trailern wie in Bad Company 3.
Dann ist bei mir echt der Hype Train des Todes am Start.
Aber richtig massiv, richtig, also dann spielen wir bis zum Release Bad Company 2, dass wir üben können.
Ich sag euch, sollten die Bad Company 3 ankündigen, werden schlagartig wieder einige Bad Company 2 soll aber voll sein.
Und die Leute sagen, ja gut, dann spielen wir noch mal, bis es rauskommt.
Ich meine 2019 ergibt eigentlich keinen Sinn, eigentlich ergibt Battlefield 2019 keinen Sinn, weil die haben ja irgendwie DLC und Gedönspläne das ganze Jahr über.
Gibt es da neue Gerüchte zu?
2020 wenn schon.
Ich will da nicht so lange drauf warten.
Es kommt 2020, wenn überhaupt.
Einfach aus dem Grund, die haben so viel Zeug auch schon angekündigt für Battlefield 5.
Was mir halt am Arsch vorbeigeht.
Aber für die Leute, die es halt spielen, ist interessant.
Aber die haben halt so viel Zeug angekündigt.
Wobei es stimmt ja gar nicht mal, dass es so viel Zeug ist.
Es war ja kaum was dabei bei Release.
Es waren weniger Maps dabei, es gab noch nicht mal eine Practice Range.
Es gab keine Practice Range zu Release bei Battlefield 5.
Die hatten allen ernst, das muss man, so Nerven muss man erstmal haben, dass man in das Hauptmenü schreibt.
Hier klicken für Practice Range und dann bei Practice Range drunter schreiben, coming soon.
So nach dem Motto, freut euch Leute, coming soon bald, Practice Range.
Schön ins Fuß geschossen.
Also ich finde, man kommt gut rein.
Also ich habe ja auch immer mal wieder Battlefield, also immer mal wieder Bad Company 2 gespielt auf dem PC.
Man kommt immer relativ gut rein.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht, dass da nur die Pros spielen.
Da spielen auch ganz viele Vollkosten, ganz viele verplante Leute spielen da auch.
Du hast mal immer wieder, hast du da schon den Kernel 5000 Typ quasi am Start.
Ja Bad Company gibt es immer noch so mindestens einen vollen Server immer.
Aber ich würde mal sagen, du findest eigentlich eher so 2, 3, 4 ganz gut gefüllte Rush Server.
Conquest gibt es auch ein paar.
Eine Battlefield 1, eine Practice Range, keine Ahnung, ich habe keine Battlefield 1 gespielt.
Die Benamung ist ja an sich schon so unglaublich fail, dass ich es gar nicht, ich habe es ja gar nicht für möglich gehalten, dass das Ding wirklich Battlefield 5 heißt.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, wie sollen sie es denn sonst nennen?
1 plus 1 hätten sie es nennen können oder so.
Und um die Sache halt nicht ganz so verwirrend zu machen, schreiben sie es ja überall V anstatt 5.
Das ist so verkackt.
Also die Benamung mit Battlefield 1 war einfach für einen Arsch.
Sie hätten es einfach Battlefield World War 1 oder so nennen können, aber 1.
Ist halt blöd, wenn man die Serie schon hochgezählt hat bis Teil 4, dann gibt es halt keinen Sinn.
Ja.
Genau, Battlefield 1943.5 hätten sie nennen können, das neue.
Oder eigentlich hätten sie es Battlefield 1944 nennen können, wenigstens.
Gab es ja glaube ich nicht, 42 gab es, 43 gab es, das war diese Arcade-Sache auf der Xbox.
Dann hätten sie es 44 nennen können.
Und ich meine, nachdem sie es historisch eh nicht allzu genau nehmen, das Video hat übelsteering.
Es wäre es auch egal gewesen, ob sie Events zeigen, die vor 1944 gewesen wären.
Ich habe mal ein bisschen die Kampagne letztens angespielt.
Also letztens ist schon ein bisschen her.
Das war ja irgendwie sehr uninspiriert.
Die Kampagne mit dem, was ist das, norwegischen Grill?
Schwedischen Grill?
Ich weiß schon gar nicht, bei welches Land es war.
Finnischen Grill?
Was war es dann?
In der Battlefield? Ich weiß nicht. Bleiben wir mal skandinavisch im Grill.
Die Kampagne, die war ja schon so emotional gemacht mit der Mutter und alles.
Aber irgendwie war es bescheuert.
Ich weiß nicht.
Und nicht, weil man den Grill gespielt hat. Das hat mich am wenigsten genervt.
Das war eigentlich egal.
Irgendwie war das auch wieder so gewollt und nicht gekonnt.
Zumal die Gegner auch einfach nur dastehen, um abgeschossen zu werden in Battlefield-Kampagnen.
Bis jetzt zu Bad Company hat das irgendwie noch gepasst, weil sich das nicht ernst genommen hat.
Aber in einem ernsten Battlefield wirkt das einfach lächerlich, die KI von Battlefield-Soldaten, KI-Soldaten.
Ich glaube, die Norweger waren es.
Die Norweger haben sich auch voll aufgeregt über die Kampagne.
Weil es muss wohl irgendwie so sein, dass das, was in der Kampagne thematisiert wird,
wo man halt das, ich glaube skandinavisch, ich glaube norwegisch war das,
was in der Kampagne von Battlefield thematisiert wird,
wo es dann halt so getan wird, als quasi die Protagonistin der Story,
als macht die da einmal Eingang quasi, schneidet sie die Nachschublieferung der Nazis ab.
Das war ja in Wirklichkeit wohl eine lange geplante Aktion mit vielen beteiligten Leuten.
Und das ist wohl auch eine Sache, die in Norwegen sehr bekannt ist, was die damals halt getrieben haben.
Und da haben die sich irgendwie in Norwegen übelst darüber aufgeregt,
dass das quasi, obwohl sie immer erzählt haben, dass das alles so historisch genau ist,
und dass das halt überhaupt nicht mit dem zu tun hat, wie es gewesen ist.
Guck mal, die Legehänne ist am Start.
Sind die Gegner blind? Guck mal, ich hab die irgendwie gefühlt, die Gegner sind übelst blind.
Guckt keiner nach hinten, ey.
War sind die dumm gewesen, die Gegner, die waren richtig blöd.
Legehänne, ja. Guck mal, mitten durch die Base.
Und jetzt das Ding auch noch Defenden wahrscheinlich, ne?
Ne, ich renn einfach weiter zur nächsten Bombe. Easy, easy. Mitten durch die Base durch.
Kein Gegner am Start.
Ah, jetzt haben sie hier schon Legehänne gemacht. Und meinen haben sie wieder entschärft. War toll.
Easy as fuck. Get rekt.
Spray, spray, spray, spray.
Der Sound von Bad Company 2 war auch übelst geil.
Man muss sagen, der Sound von jedem Battlefield-Game ist eigentlich geil.
Aber das Wartape-Setting von Bad Company 2 ist für mich immer noch unerreicht.
Find ich sogar besser als Battlefield 3.
Ich mein, vom Detailgrad hat sich da enorm viel getan, ne?
Guckt euch das mal an. Hier ist es im Prinzip ein leerer Container mit einem M-Com drin und drei Stühlen.
Vergleicht das mal mit einem Haus in Battlefield 5. Das ist ein riesen Unterschied dazwischen.
Aber...
Das ist ein riesen Unterschied zwischen Battlefield 3 und Battlefield 4.
Vergleicht das mal mit einem Haus in Battlefield 5. Das ist ein riesen Unterschied dazwischen.
Aber das macht halt Reißnass-Gameplay auch nicht raus.
Ja, das war schon ein soo leises Game.
Das einzige Battlefield, was da Fabian gespielt hat...
Was zum Teufel geht da ab?
Oh, geh weg.
Sellout-Mode.
Warum guck ich mir eigentlich alle Videos von mir an?
Ja, das war's.
Easy.
60 FPS.
Guck mal, wir können sogar hochstellen auf 1440p 60 FPS.
Mal gucken, ob ich's schaff. Mal gucken, ob ich's schaff.
Der Sprung ist ziemlich... Ja, ja, ja.
Oh, beim ersten... First try.
Der Sprung ist gar nicht so einfach gewesen.
Oh, NA aim, NA aim.
Alter, was hält denn der Typ aus?
Ich kann mich ja auch noch mal an die Runde erinnern.
Aber es wird geflankt.
Es wird geflankt.
Bad Company 2 hatte halt auch jede Klasse geile Waffen.
Man konnte mit jeder... Bad Company 2 hatte so die Taktik...
Jeder ist OP.
Was ich an sich nicht schlecht fand.
Was? Was? Nebenrauschen? Was ist nebenrauschen?
Der G2A Sellout Mode. Oh ja, das hat sich gelohnt.
Ich hab aber mit dem G2A Sellout Mode aus zwei Gründen aufgehört.
Erstens, hatte ich keinen Bock, mich so regelmäßig zu verpflichten, Videos zu machen.
Also ich hab mich nicht verpflichtet, so und so viele Videos zu machen.
Allerdings indirekt schon, weil ich gesagt hab, ich mach so und so auf dem Monat die Intro vor dem Video.
Was mich quasi indirekt dazu verpflichtet hat, Videos zu machen.
Weil G2A jetzt nun auch nicht der unkontroverseste Laden ist.
Aber gelohnt hat es.
Wir haben schon ordentlich was bezahlt.
Also man kann sich überlegen, das was ich für diese Sniper-Elite habe,
Geschichte gekriegt habe, und das war auch schon ordentlich, habe ich in zwei Monaten G2A gekriegt.
Weniger, eineinhalb Monate G2A ungefähr.
Da kommen ja noch Affiliate und so dazu.
Also G2A hat sich zu der Zeit wirklich schon huge gelohnt.
Ich hab aber kaum was bezahlt.
Ich hab aber kaum was von meinem YouTube-Money ausgegeben,
deswegen bin ich da jetzt auch insofern recht entspannt.
Weil ich jetzt einfach, ich hab Reserve.
Ich muss gar keine Videos machen, ich hab jetzt, ey, hab ich genug.
Was schon die letzten zehn Jahre angesammelt hat.
Kann ich jetzt, falls irgendwas passiert, hab ich erst mal was.
ONA-Aim.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich dicke Kohle machen würde, ne?
Ich mein, die letzte Zeit ohne Videos sollte es jedem einleuchten, definitiv nicht.
Ja, das war auch, das war tatsächlich bei Company 2 ein bisschen blöd,
dass man sich gegenseitig killen konnte so oft.
Wobei ich es gar nicht so übel fand.
Bei Company 2 war ja rein Server-Side die Hit-Detection.
Das hat ja auch den Vorteil gehabt, man ist nicht, man hatte nicht so merkwürdige Tode.
Also man wurde nicht so einfach um die Ecke gekillt und sowas.
Und wenn schon um die Ecke, weil...
Easy-Jetski-Skills.
Ich glaub's denn, ey, ich sitz da und guck mir Altepetcom von den zwei Videos an.
Übrigens danke für die Follows.
Falls es noch irgendwelche gegeben haben, ich hab net geguckt, ich guck mal kurz.
Wenn sie 82 Fleisch kotze, Wheatley 2016, weiß ich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich war's das.
Ziemlich flüssig, oder?
Also ich hoffe ja echt, das wird bei Company 3.
Und was richtig cool wäre, wenn sie vielleicht die ein oder anderen Leute noch auftreiben können.
Die noch wissen, was bei Company 2 gut gemacht hat.
Guck mal, das war ein nicer Schuss, oder?
Der war... oh, der war nice, der war nice.
Ich hoffe, es hat keiner mein Name gesehen.
Der ist so dumm, mein PC-Name von Inward Company.
Der ist so richtig, so richtig cringe.
Ja, also auch dieses Reparieren im Heli...
Der Server laggt übrigens, oder?
Dieses Reparieren im Heli und so, das fand ich eigentlich auch ganz cool.
Zumal du die ja immer noch mit dem AT4 relativ schnell bashen konntest.
Das ihr auch kennt, ja.
Gucken, ob ich jetzt wieder First Try hier hochschaff.
Der Sprung ist nämlich gar nicht so einfach.
Nee, jetzt funktioniert es nicht.
Und das fand ich auch nice, dass es so Dinge gab, die man richtig üben konnte, ja.
Also, ich mein, das ist was, was auch so ein bisschen fehlt.
Ich mein, es ist offensichtlich sehr schwierig, hier hochzukommen.
Aber wenn man hochkommt, ist das...
...saumäßig gut, du bist direkt im Rücken von den Gegnern drinnen.
Und wenn man das geübt hat, da schnell hochzukommen, ist die Base quasi fast sicher, wenn man das mit ein paar Leuten macht.
Der rutscht da runter.
So was fehlt, ja.
In Battlefield 3 konntest du auch schön über die Felswände hüpfen und so.
Da konntest du echt kreative Wege laufen, aber das haben sie ja alles abgestellt, irgendwie.
Das werden sie aber ganz schön gebashed, die Gegner.
Das war ja offensichtlich nicht im Sinne des Erfinders, dass man mit einer Drohne hochfliegen kann.
Ich meine, ich stehe mitten in der Base von den Gegnern, weil sie mit ihrem eigenen MG rum und die checken sie irgendwie.
Die sind auch schon irgendwie ein wenig beschränkt in ihrer Auffassungsfähigkeit.
Doch so momentan noch ein Spiel aktiv, also so richtig aktiv wie die Battlefields damals nicht.
Ich habe mal Insurgency runtergeladen, mal gucken, ob das was ist.
Und ich da ruhe.
Die Musik passt übelst gut, Gegner werden geowned.
Naja, ich würde sagen, ich gehe jetzt mal was essen. Genug alle Videos geguckt.
Infinite-Klarname, ja.
Genug Videos geguckt.
Ja, das war heute irgendwie sinnlos streben, haben nicht das gemacht, was wir machen wollten.
Aber die Gegner werden schon schon zerstört. Macht's gut, bis morgen, oder so.
See you.